Hi everybody!
Hi Hi!
Hello!
Welcome back to Control!
I'm totally in control.
You just watch part one, thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you!
The board welcomes you back, director.
Yeah, wait, what if I have you guys stop calling me boss and
have you guys call me director instead?
How in wake, too, now available.
Wait, it's so funny, there's, like, ads.
There's ads, literally, like, actually, when I first opened
the game, this pops up.
So, hola, hola, hola, hola, hola, hola, hola, hola, hola.
welcome back director as you wish director no i think i like
bot i don't know you can call me whichever director bus
anything hello yeah okay director sama where where are we
adding the sama from i am just a maid i do not deserve such
high title bizarrely you can't even buy Yeah, Alan Wake 2
is, unfortunately, stuck to the, uh, it is stuck to the Epic
store, but I already have it.
So, um, I think Alan Wake 2, I either got it for very cheap
or free.
I definitely got Alan Wake 1 for free on the Epic store,
which is great.
Slow day at work today.
Early video is pretty good.
Samantha
Lamping Good luck with work though Good luck with work I'm
glad it's slow It's apparently A long weekend In the US I
did not know I did not realize You're the director Busu
You're the bus Busu Director Bus Bus Director I'm confused
too Thank you for coming with me To the AEW show I'm taking
you to the new Neoprene movie today Burger Guy Oh my gosh
Wait Do you think he's going to there do you think neil
breen will be there if so please wait which is the new neil
breen movie hold on i'm looking this up this is important
information yeah labor day it's a labor day in the us let's
see uh neil breen
i'm gonna go to his twitter neil breen i cannot wait to
experience the new neil the new breen the only thing is the
last movie i doubt mr breen will be there you don't know you
don't know his new movie is dire duplicity oh i just see it
seventh indie feature film dire i haven't watched any
trailer on it or anything the last one that i watched hold
on um was the one that he made like during covid which was
like oh nearly like 90 actually it might have been a hundred
percent Dug.
Supertime wasn't working for you.
Oh, no.
Oh, but thank you.
You could have just given up.
It's okay.
Thank you, Kavo.
I appreciate it always.
Thank you so much.
Tortured Crossing.
That's the one I watched.
The one where he's twins and eight.
Yeah, Kade the Torture Crossing.
That one was rough.
It was like so...
Oh, gosh.
For those who have never seen a Neil Breen, movie we gotta
do a watch along or something we've gotta do a watch along
of like the hits the new ones are fine like kade kade was
not so great i'll be honest but um this one might be better
but his like his are so his movies are hashtag eyes on brain
and when i saw control on the schedule i thought min's gonna
love the spooky vibes and throwing rocks at people glad
you're having fun Thanks, Kempo!
I got the Cinemarol Godzilla Happy Meal Toy after watching
the Roadrunner cartoons movie.
I like it was great.
Wait, that's so awesome!
Wait, there's Cinemarol Godzilla Happy Meal Toys.
What is going on?
He's a master of cinematography.
How can I describe a Neil Green movie?
Somewhat nonsensical pretentious um um Neil Breen's ass he's
he's like naked in so many of these movies um a fever dream
of of stuff but there is like an underlying message but the
it's like maybe the right message definitely the wrong
messenger it's very nothing beats double down absolute
madness and congratulations on the upcoming kitty okay i so
okay i have to talk about kitty i have to talk about kitty
let me tell my giant mint the plushie arrived hey how about
thank you for getting it i forgot i even ordered it oh my
gosh well thank you for ordering it thank you for having
foresight i guess the man is a visionary of sorts yes yes
yes god complex plus abuse of eid bay laptops parts only
Yeah, he will wreck, he will wreck a hundred fake, like, uh,
what, movie prop laptops.
He loves doing that.
Neil Breen again, I was hoping I'd see the last of him in
City 14.
Wait, what is that?
But yes, kitty.
Kitty.
I today went to a shelter.
I went to a shelter.
They were so nice.
They had me sit in a room full of kitties and they were
like, enjoy to...
your heart's content and i was like
it was oh half-life two reference oh sorry i was totally not
even thinking of half-life
thank you i gotta finish that by the way don't i it's actual
heaven it was amazing it was so amazing and i would sit down
and little kiddies would come up to me and I say kitties but
I also mean cats um because I'm not actually going to get a
kitty because kittens get adopted very easily I was like you
know the cat that I liked is a little bit older but not like
so old purple zino welcome to membush oh welcome back thank
you thank you thank you all cats is kitties so true so true
um he's a couple years and uh so um did you choose the cat
or did the cat choose you you know really like i chose the
cat i saw him and it was love at first sight i was like i
could not stop thinking of this cat i had other cats on me
around me pet i was petting them it was so cute and the name
you guys i can't wait to tell you his name it's so perfect
it's so perfect and so um cats are just big kitties and they
love to it's true it's true he is so cute he is so so oh my
gosh when i when i was like i think i want this kitty they
were like oh my gosh good choice but um they they i I'm a
little worried I told them that I would come back next week
to get him but they were like you know I didn't pay for
anything so I don't really have like a reservation or
anything they were like you could take him home today and I
was like ah I I I work later oh so you know my my main cafe
isn't really super set up for a cat at the moment anyway so
he's kind of on hold.
He's kind of on hold, but they were saying that, like, if
anybody comes in and is just like, I must have him, that,
you know, they could get him.
And I'm like, I've been in contact email, like, I literally
just emailed them.
And I was like, hey, I even, I was going to go in later next
week, and then I was like, I need to go in earlier.
I need to go in earlier.
So I changed the day for what I'm going in next week.
So that's why I am, I'm not saying much about him.
I'm not, uh, posting anything about him or anything,
anything, anything about him.
Um, until I have him safe in my cafe and he is acclimated
and feeling good and all of this and that.
Because, you know, I don't even i really really really
really want to be so cute but um but yeah so uh if somebody
else goes and grabs him then obviously i don't get him which
would be so sad first come first first come first kitty uh
well i made him stand out to you
he's so cute good luck on the new kitty i hope everything
works out perfectly i have to walk a few hundred feet from
my local shelter because two cats is as many as i can handle
spank thank you for the pink thank you i know actually i
thought about getting a second one um but i think i'll just
get the one guy for now he seemed like he seemed he seemed
like um he was very playful but not involved with the other
cats in fact he would go up to other cats and they would
just like hiss and bop him on the head and i was like oh my
gosh cancel stream and save him i honestly i thought i was
like but i really wanted to play control at the same time i
don't have a good time to play it otherwise until next week
so i was like i was like okay well i will i will Hold out.
I'll be strong.
Tim-Tan!
Thank you so much for the five gift.
Thank you always.
Thank you.
It's okay.
Again, my cafe is really not set up for a cat at the very
moment.
So, one second.
Oh my gosh.
My ghost crew shirt arrived in the mail yesterday.
Yippee!
Thanks for getting Thanks for getting it.
You're stronger than me.
I wouldn't be able to function until I brought him home.
I'm honest.
I am nervous about because he's kind of newer to the
shelter.
And so, you know, I'm worried that someone will snatch him
up.
Because he's really freaking cute.
But, uh, yeah.
So.
But I felt bad canceling.
Good luck with Kitty.
Thank you, Origin.
you what you're saying you should be this should be a super
short stream and then you could should go get cat we'll see
we'll see we'll see um now i'm nervous as not even by cat
even if someone does there are always cats in need of a home
i was bouncing between like four different cats i'll be
honest like there were so many that were so sweet I was
like, this guy is so cute, and this guy is so cute, and this
girl is so cute, and I was, I was, you know, mmm, get them
all and become a cat lady.
I volunteer in my local shelter, and I have to say thank you
for giving a grown kitty a chance.
They're often overlooked.
I hope you get them.
Yeah, thank you.
Thank you for volunteering.
That's really awesome.
I love volunteering at pet shelters.
Congrats on the cat, Minto.
Don't congratulate me yet.
But thank you, thank you, thank you.
There were, I'm gonna be honest, there were some kittens.
There was a four-month little kitten that I was like...
Oh, I won't get a kitten.
I won't get a kitten.
I didn't want a kitten.
Because kittens are so, like, rambunctious and crazy.
I was like, this cat, this little kitten is going to be,
like,
take care of him well but make sure to teach him properly to
nyan yeah oh he was so cute i was giving him chulu you know
chudus i was giving him a chudu and he was like bonk in his
head on the on the chudu he's he's a couple years old but he
acts like a kitten so so cute adult have their character
developed already that's a plus it's a plus and a minus no
because like kitten claws are light saber sharp is so true
um because like as a kitten if you're like i want my cat to
be a lap cat or i want my cat to jump on my shoulder you can
train them from a young age if you get an adult cat you know
they kind of already have their personality their eyes
they're either gonna do that or they're not you know what i
mean he's a great a dumbass yeah he's so stupid i'm going to
that shelter and adopting the stupidest cat see there if you
don't no you'll adopt him a stray cat followed me home a few
months ago and i named her baby she just sat on my lap for
the first time a few minutes ago that's huge oh my gosh
arrow mage that's huge that's huge but yeah i'm i really I'm
gonna go get you.
Like, right now.
But I will resist.
Maybe.
Then we should play the game, so I can get through a lot of
the game if I do decide to go get Cat, right?
So let's get started.
We just went to...
We just, like, quantum leapt to the motel.
So now I am here.
Give me a...
Wait, this is not the motel.
Wait.
Oh, traverse the ocean view motel.
Huh?
Wait.
Eh?
Huh?
Starts you at the last save point.
I don't remember how to get there.
Uh, do I go through?
I go, oh, never mind.
Uh, so I beat that guy.
Okay, hold on.
We're jumping.
I'm...
Okay.
I'm aiming.
And they're firing.
Okay.
But this room...
Oh my gosh, I was gonna say it should be saved!
Oh my
gosh.
Oh my gosh.
Why did they have...
Oh my god.
No!
Uh...
That was like a homing missile!
Okay.
I think maybe I...
Oh my god.
I didn't, I thought because we just finished the boss in
here, that it would be a fire, it would be clear.
Clearly not.
Okay, this is fine.
It's not fine.
Screw you!
There were more!
Where are they?
Where is he?
I don't even...
I tried to grab it.
Oh my god, there's even more!
Let me grab their health.
Oh, I'm fully health, fully healed.
Where are they?
Oh.
Screw you!
Where are you shooting me from?
Oh.
Oh my god, they're everywhere.
Stop it!
What the hell is going on?
Ah!
Oh my god.
Did he die?
That was a warning shot.
Where'd he go?
At least I don't have...
Eee!
Really?
Oh.
Screw you.
Leave me alone.
I need to get up there, I think.
Pretty sure that's where it was.
Did I get him?
No.
Ah!
Where are they?
Come on, let me at you!
Yeah!
Oh, there's a long...
Oh my god.
They're never ending.
ah i can't even see there we go i got him finally how many
more are there
oh my god oh my god they're never ending oh my god they're
never ending oh my god please
wave leave me alone please
what was that
Oh my gosh Oh my gosh
Well I Um Had a chance to Uh Get try everything again
Explosive start to the stream Truly We saw Uh I guess
nothing here Okay hotline chamber Goodness gracious Goodness
gracious Oh, my gosh.
Pretty sure I've, like, read all of this.
If there was anything.
The Bureau.
I'm gonna eat some mold after that.
Wait, wait for eight is making me go crazy.
You got this, Nan.
You can be patient.
You got this.
It's so soon.
All right, lines.
A twice and a thrice.
Have we been here before?
I've stayed at a lot of roadside motels across the country.
On the road, on the run, under the radar.
This feels like all of them, like something recognized from
a dream.
Got scared by a minke plush notice.
Thank you, Chancellor.
Wow.
We got the Western blend.
Visit Nevada, state of freedom.
This is my key.
Hello.
Oh, I almost said that.
Can I turn this off?
It's very loud.
Oh, I don't have my powers.
Oh my god, it's so loud.
Wait, are we going to Nevada or Miami?
Where are we?
Oh my gosh.
janitor
I don't have my power so interesting
Look at the tiniest TV ever.
Oh my god I couldn't make out like one two people That's so
small Rosary!
Thank you so much for the red!
Hello!
Rosary!
Thanks for reading!
Hi everybody, I'm playing Control.
I guess you have to, thank you!
Dargo, thank you!
TV the size of a microwave.
I'm gonna watch burgers rotating in that or something.
Why is the music so creepy back here?
interesting maybe that door is open though oh this oh this
is the pull it a pulley is this like a puzzle or I don't
recall this outfit it's some sort of DLC but look at it oh
yeah there's a whole lot to look at yeah baby yeah baby I
didn't see a I'm quite distracted by the...
Oh my gosh, I used to have that exact pencil sharpener.
Can we turn this down a little bit?
Maybe I'm supposed to ring this a couple times.
Hello?
Whoa, a different door opens every time I ring it!
Neat.
I think we went in this way.
one first.
The key has a black pyramid on it.
And that's the one that we were trying to get before.
I got Mickey Bush to the end.
It's a huge!
Tino-chan, thank you!
Mickey, I found out that Freakazoid is on Toby now.
I was thinking of watching it tonight after this.
Do you like Freakazoid at all?
I watched a little bit of Freakazoid.
Oh, that's a me!
One more?
A twice?
And a thrice?
Whoa.
The prophecy of the of the painting came true.
Moshi moshi.
Directors can call the board long distance.
the astral plane channel oh we're back here again hello
board hello board oh boy is it one of these guys again the
hotline will allow you to contact interdimensional or sorry
extra dimensional entities am i talking to this guy on the
phone Oh, that sounds not so good.
Ah!
Oh!
Oops.
I think she could climb.
There's a hole there, everybody.
Watch out.
Watch your step.
Oh my god.
Run!
I don't think he wants to talk to us.
Wrong!
Wrong number!
It's like an angry dog.
You can't actually kill it.
Okay.
Oh, it even hurt me.
Where even... Where's the... Where's the phone?
Look!
Wrong number!
I'm sorry!
I hear it, I hear it.
There.
You did smack it with a rock.
I did.
And I'll do it again.
You think I can reach that?
Ah!
Nice.
We're too good.
You can contact us in the hotline collectibles menu.
We expect compulsive slash weekly calls.
Oh, I am tall.
It's awesome.
Dr. Darling!
to any typical network a direct line to the astral plane and
the board and my hypothesis is under the right conditions to
other planes of existence as well
director here a director needs a team my management team
these people know the secrets of the Bureau as well as I do
some even better darling to my Oh, that guy's gone, though.
Marshall especially, my head of operations.
She sees right through me.
She knows I don't like relying on people.
The only person you should fail is yourself.
Who was the girl we were talking to before?
I don't think it was Marshall.
Hmm.
Okay.
Speak.
Emily!
That's who it was.
The hotline.
I can reach Trench.
Well, listen to him.
He feels more like an echo.
An echo with important info.
I need to get back to Emily.
I got all sorts of like...
Oh, okay.
Wait.
Um...
People react strongly when I tell them about you.
Hmm.
Is it too soon to tell Emily?
She might be able to help.
Hmm.
You can watch all his phone calls now.
Oh, that's not what I meant to do, my bad.
Hold on, I'm just trying to pull up the menu.
Wait, wait, how do I...
Okay, there we go.
Collectibles.
Did we...
Oh, hotline security log.
Oh.
All visitors must check in.
Director trench, director trench.
Castorian.
trench custodian carol bishop custodian
bill everett that's not the guy that the custodian we were
we first met though no yeah it's a different custodian from
the other guy than the other guy
ah t yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's what that's him yes i
remember but interesting object should be inaccessible for
the for use except to the director object is a 1960s era red
bake light telephone the rotary dial has been replaced with
a black knob of unknown purpose the phone weighs I don't why
why oh my gosh never it's so rude to ask a lady her way it's
redacted a cool fact that may or may not be meta related to
Remedy Universe because they love meta stuff.
The voice actor for Director Trench is also Max Payne, and
Dr. Darling is Alan Wake.
Yeah, yeah, I didn't know that.
Well, I didn't know Max Payne.
I didn't know Trench was Max Payne, but I knew Dr. Darling
was Alan Wake.
Everybody told me that last time, yeah.
The object allows the director to communicate with the
board?
Question mark?
Madlibs with the or we're madlibbing the the Wikipedia entry
for this thing if used by anyone other than the director the
object will cause lethal redacted the
object is currently bound to director trench not that's not
us what's that is it not bad oh well I guess it doesn't
bound me and like we can contact him object spontaneously
manifested in the director's office placed on the desk
director Northmore was the first known bureau agent to use
it a battery of tests were run on the object including
redacted and redacted but its origin remains unknown and now
we have all of these very cool the dictatorship i don't know
if i remember watching this one
oh oh
directorship i was like wait what the direct i just Well,
now that I'm in charge, it's a dictatorship.
No, I'm just kidding.
Okay, okay, okay.
One thing about this game is it feeds you a ton of info.
So, oh no, you think that room is going to be absolutely
infested again?
I would have...
I would have done all of this last time had I known that I
would have to go through it.
Whoa.
Wait, this is new.
Right?
It was not open before.
My room!
Whoa!
Oh!
I'm custodian!
I need to clean this up.
It's...
It's throwing off my groove.
Oh my gosh!
Custodian!
Please!
I'm scared.
Ooh.
Mint control.
That's me.
Seek shelter.
What the heck is this?
Don't touch.
Don't tell me what to do.
I'm the director.
Now we have clearance for...
A room over here, no?
Um, but also, okay.
Where the heck is Emily?
Was she through here?
Central ex- Oh, yes, she must be.
There- Nope, that's not her.
Just kidding.
Hello!
Address me.
This should be like Metal Gear where they're like, How's it
going, boss?
Give me an order, boss.
Technological restrictions.
Address me.
The oldest house imposes certain limitations on our bureau,
but by far the most restrictive is the inability to use
certain technological instruments.
The oldest house does not allow devices that receive or emit
any Radio?
No.
Radio waves.
Any redacted signals.
Sorry, this game isn't as good as Metal Gear.
Don't say, though.
That office needs Kovalsky to clean it up.
So true.
We need our crime scene cleaner guy.
Radio waves are the only transmittable signals in the oldest
house.
Oh, so it's not radio waves.
And even those are often unreliable.
and consciousness is taken into account it could be that
certain pieces of technology are too new in the cultural
redacted for the oldest house to redacted them obviously
similarly these items have not been known to become
receptacles for altered status technology may be moving at
too fast a pace for the redacted to occur modern technology
tends to disappear and break here Sometimes quite violently.
Redacted agents have been injured by...
Cell phones exploding in their pockets while entering the
oldest house.
Whoa.
Yeah, maybe digital.
We're in an analog stage here.
Let's go.
Ring light.
They're streamers.
Minto, how are you liking the game so far?
I'm really enjoying the game so far.
And there's lots to...
Did I not explore up here before?
Do not...
Or don't read confidential correspondence.
It's not just rude.
It's illegal.
Where can I get some mold?
Any mold in here?
Any mold to eat?
I'm craving mold.
Is mold on the menu?
There's so much up here.
Shifted bathroom complaint.
Not even the bathrooms are safe.
and I know you can't control building shifts, but the
executive level restroom has been missing for weeks now.
I worked my ass off in Islamabad station for three years.
I've earned the right to a nice workplace shitter.
If you can't bring it back, at least find out where it went.
Honestly, valid complaint.
Oh, we got launch efficiency.
Launch energy.
cost minus eight percent right now we have uh more health
which honestly kind of saves my butt saves my booty
sometimes i
guess i really didn't look around here i have i'm so lost
this place is like an absolute i mean like the shifts alone
are gonna make this quite a troubling map to explore but the
fact that i only play once a week and my brain a small means
it's even tougher.
Boss makes a dollar, I make a dime, and I'd poop on company
time, but the bathroom is called out sick.
The bathroom, astral projected somewhere.
You get used to it.
Emily, okay, we did find her.
Perfect.
We can, let's, uh, do a different outfit every, every time
we play.
We'll do this one today.
Tactical response today.
Oh, I love the ponytail!
Oh, cute!
Okay.
I want to check out this area too.
Or...
You have yet to unlock the best outfit.
Well, exciting.
I just got to keep playing them.
We have clearance for this area now.
We have level 1 clearance.
I do want to go back to the director's office because I
believe there was a door that said level 1 clearance needed.
Sorry, I'm just looking for things to read.
Oh, wait, this is a radio.
Oh,
wait.
Oh, wait.
I missed a birthday?
I'm so sorry.
Hey, boss gonna ask for a little birthday fence.
Oh, 36 this year.
You're 36 years young combats!
Happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday!
There was a file on a director's desk.
Okay, we'll go back, because actually, I do not know if
maybe talking to Emily...
Whoa, what happened here?
If talking to Emily will trigger something, you know, so...
Was there something?
Aha!
There was, thank you very much.
Trench Bureau funding.
To all executive staff, I know there is some concern
regarding our operations exceeding the annual budget.
So long as we operate within the oldest house, we are
obscured from scrutiny in many respects.
If our budget demands are not exorbitant to the point of
drawing attention, then they will be granted by the U.S.
Treasury without question.
The FBC is just another line and another spreadsheet that
some lowly accountant won't even notice.
Their eyes will skip over us as if we weren't even there.
The nature of the oldest house allows us certain freedoms in
how we operate.
Our being here is no accident.
Regards Zachariah Trench, director of the Federal Bureau of
Control.
X.
Director.
Yeah, get owned account.
Let me double check since we're right here.
Let's double check if this was a level one clear.
It is.
Oh!
Spooky room.
Agent death notification.
Mr. Amissant Potts!
No!
Chip!
I regret to inform you that your son Graham Potts was killed
in active duty this past week.
While the details surrounding his death are classified, I am
honored to tell you that he died in a service of his
country.
You can be proud of his courage in the face of danger and
his commitment to protecting our nation against her enemies.
He will be remembered by his comrades and colleagues.
I sincerely regret the pain this message will bring you.
Take some solace in knowing that his sacrifice helped
protect the country he loved so much.
His effects will be returned to you with all speed.
Sincerely yours, Howard J.
Murray, Deputy Chief of Communications Federal Bureau of
Control.
Oh, 7.2.
Graham Potts.
Remember, there was, like, that thing that said, like, when
you're sending out letters like this, avoid these languages
and say these languages.
Graham Chip Potts finally fell off the countertop.
Tale of his oldest time.
Oh, let me open that.
as it can be.
When do I get to make stuff?
I want to watch all of these, right?
Well, imagine.
Imagine the tea.
All the juicy, juicy bits of info.
Alright, cool.
Well, we got to go in there.
I believe there was another...
Wait, there was another room, wasn't there?
Did I go in here?
Yes?
No.
awesome we're getting lots of stuff more material soon okay
cool I feel like I'm collecting a lot of material and they
got this weird plant thing too what is this it looks like
it's about to start singing and talking to me
hmm funny thing funny thing there was another clearance one
room though before we saw Emily wasn't there am I crazy am I
crazy wasn't there wait oh no that's a radium it's very
tubulary the flower from mario wonder it's gonna start
telling me the time does anyone have that mario clock i kind
of want one because it's so unhinged
her eyes gloss over the post-it room uh no it didn't i
literally tried checking it and it's clearance Ford.
Don't gaslight me.
Don't even try.
I even remember what number it is.
Wham bam!
Thank you, ma'am.
Don't ever question my authority again.
Oh, this one.
This is the one I was thinking of.
Oh.
I mean, I imagine everything around here is probably safe
asterisk because of we've, I mean, we've controlled the
area, no?
So don't worry about that plan.
It's totally normal and do not, not up to any suspicious
activity.
Yeah.
Chad, I'm gonna question it.
You will not!
Paral utility.
Examination of perinatural topics.
Objects of power in their periutility.
Uh-oh, Cartman's got the authority.
Mint Cartman.
My authority.
How dare you question my authority.
Objects of power are unique in their capacity to grant
certain individuals paranatural abilities.
We call these individuals parayutilitarians.
What a mouthful.
Respect to my authority.
time you sound just like him i feel like i should be
offended by that comment
the potency of these abilities depend on the para
utilitarian using the redacted object of power as an example
some per utilitarian can achieve a throw distance of
redacted well others are only capable of as little of as
little as redacted as see dr darling yeah yeah i get to
throw things and you get to poop yourself what exactly
determines an individual's paranatural competence is unknown
but it is largely believed that some redacted exist within
the body and that like all muscles it can be exercised
watch the full versions of darling's presentations they give
you more context also fun to watch we will that's a good
idea we will do that not quite yet we will do it a bit later
maybe but I think that would be fun yeah this area is safe
asterisk just like chat is responsible asterisk aka it's all
relative to continue my analysis I have officially requested
access to the north more records considering he is one of
the most accomplished peri-utilitarians the bureau has ever
seen dr darling is still considering this request refer to
people pop people pop or
Hey guys!
Oh, oh, this is open.
I was gonna be like, hey guys, can you see me?
Undefined reading.
Oh, I can't use my powers in here.
Okay, very interesting.
I don't even have a gun.
So it is safe.
I deem it safe.
Okay, that's just that door.
Awesome, let's go talk to Emily.
Wait!
Luckily, our budget has expanded for any and all damages I
may do.
I'm driving through the car equivalent of a Left 4 Dead map
with stream cutting in and out and Vid just told me to poop
myself.
Is everything alright?
Yeah, no super chat in driving.
Jesse, did you get the hotline?
I mean, how is it out there?
The comms, the hiss?
Sorry.
You made it.
I'm glad.
Emily?
She's kind of scared me.
Let's talk.
Of course.
What?
She's kind of scared me.
Why was she like that?
Oh, hello.
I'm trying to...
Sorry.
Initial impressions.
This is about me.
That'd be so funny.
Initial encounters with the entity known as the hiss have
revealed various behavioral...
I'm at a really long red light.
I am wearing...
Get off your phone!
you like her smiling
most notably the hiss are is the hiss is able to invade or
corrupt control points altered items and even humans
radically changing their behavior yeah they also have homing
missiles and i don't like that part curiously any person
wearing one of the wearable hra devices that dr darling has
been distributing over the past weeks was not affected by
this corruption The only known exception to this fact is the
new director, Jesse Faden.
That's me, who possesses an inherent immunity to the Hiss.
This could indicate that she has already been corrupted, but
her behavior is so in contrast of that of the other Hiss
that I have dismissed the theory.
My final observation comes from Ms. Faden herself.
She is able to cleanse material and organisms of the Hiss
corruption.
We tested this ability on a Hiss corrupted entity, but
unfortunately the process seems to kill the host.
physiology becomes reliant on the hiss more work to be done
refer to refile redacted okay so we're just reading her
diary basically all right let's talk i got the hotline i
could make out what chunch is saying now incredible what did
he say he talked about his management team people who knew
the bureau's secrets your boss darling tomasi but He's gone.
He has gone.
Oh.
He's the head of security.
And Marshall?
Marshall.
Helen Marshall is head of operations.
She's tough.
Ex-CIA.
She took her rangers and went to the research sector to
secure the HRA production.
She hasn't come back.
This lady's face gets me.
Someone who could help us.
I don't know why Jesse looks so normal and Emily is like...
How do I get there?
It's impossible because of the internal lock-in.
I tore back her her mouth.
that can only be done in the maintenance sector normally you
take the sector elevator down there it connects all the
sectors but it won't work while the lockdown is in effect we
already got past one lockdown mm-hmm maybe I can find the
way Jesse look with no prep no training in this extreme
situation you are doing phenomenally well and all that in
the his can't seem to affect you Well, they have for the
kill reaction.
I would love to have some tests on you.
If you agree, that is.
Oh.
We could find out something that would help us.
Tests.
Oh.
I don't know.
She might find out about you.
But I wouldn't mind understanding more myself.
Okay.
If you think it will help.
Early remedy tech.
Great.
I'll check the internal documentation for any lockdown
bypasses.
But Jesse looks totally normal.
She looks good.
darling and marshal and i'll look for a way inside the
maintenance sector the sooner we find one the sooner i reach
this override
all right it's always gonna there's always like a some level
of uncanny valley and games that kind of try to mimic a real
person Moshi Moshi.
Janitor.
Department of Maintenance.
Look at that file right there.
I want to read that.
I want to read.
That's meant for reading.
A tea.
Oh.
Whoa.
Oh, warm floaty people.
What is this?
Couldn't they find any other lights, light colors?
Oh, complete admission too.
Unknown caller.
Hmm, search for a way into the maintenance sector.
Okay.
How do I get there?
Hi, Jesse.
Hi.
Um, I think we did ask about these already, or most of them.
I'm sure I'll have more questions soon just let me know
thanks okay do you hear that someone's singing where's it
coming from I
don't hear singing oh oh sounds like it's coming from the
elevator she's also talking to herself
What?
Oh, I kind of hear it.
Which way was this elevator over here?
Who were you talking to?
Trench and Darling arguing a couple weeks ago.
Trench was furious.
You don't think, darling...
Oh!
What would the Bureau's golden child have to gain from
killing the boss?
Does this say elevator?
Die, Lord.
First, meet me in the maintenance.
Okay.
Oh, maintenance!
Like I said before, the janitor is a friendly face.
Oh!
Yes.
Daddy.
Ooh.
Neat.
Thank you so much for the 10 gift and trust in him.
Time to clean, Jesse!
The maintenance sector is the janitor domain.
If I can find Atee here...
Atee can help me reach the override.
Maybe it was you who got me into the oldest house with the
lockdown on.
Maybe it was Atee.
It felt like he made the elevator appear that took me to
Trench's office.
Hmm.
Is Atee guiding me too?
I see nice.
I see good.
Okay, well, we can't go in there.
Let's see.
Alright, let's go.
Proper, proper down and around.
Just in case somebody...
I get ambushed.
A scary red room.
I see the gut.
Okay.
You can upgrade our control points.
Oh, it didn't.
Is that what it mentioned?
Oh, shoot.
I missed it then.
That's okay.
I'll do so at
Taco Map.
Yeah, but like, my goodness.
What?
I think I see people floating.
The directorial override is right there in the control.
Oh, yes.
Those guys are gonna...
How do we get there?
definitely want to eat my face they don't like me I don't
like them oh yeah the map I have been told I mean honestly
like I've been told that the map is not awesome wait it
shows no like a way over here no or am i crazy is it oh it's
this part yeah we can't get in okay
yeah okay gotcha so we're trying to unlock that door gotcha
gotcha gotcha
who else who else wants this
Oh, shoot.
We're fine.
I couldn't grab anything else with the E.
Okay.
All right.
We got this.
Moving target is harder to hit.
Keep moving.
Yeah, I'm trying.
Okay.
All right.
It's fine.
We can get back there easy.
The directorial override is right there.
Minto going Leroy Jenkins.
Leroy!
Please.
Come on.
You want a piece of this?
I know you're up there.
Thank it.
I broke it.
Nice.
Oh, shoot.
He didn't get damaged at all.
We got him.
We're fine.
Maybe.
I can't tell if somebody's... anybody's still here.
Oh, there's a thing.
Hold on.
Let me heal.
Sometimes I just gotta, like, die by assessing the situation
first, you know?
Obviously.
As always.
Oh!
Cleanse the point.
But this is good.
Now we can, uh...
We can do the upgrades here too.
Being the canary in the mine.
Yeah.
So this opened up.
My bad.
Is this important?
Guess not.
abilities astral constructs is this weapon forms upgrade
grip oh i need more source and more ritual impulse and this
chatter has a high stopping power with a shatter scatter
shot that devastates grouped enemies at closer oh so we can
like change the type of gun
Should we try it?
Shatter is shotgun mode.
Oh, so it's like close range.
Oh yeah, duh.
It literally says devastates grouped enemies at close range.
Heck yeah.
Oh, nice.
And then mods.
Ooh, construct a random weapon mod.
Gotcha.
Common common common Construct levels Reef This is just a
mod gotcha That's so funny That's interesting Hold on one
second I'm trying to readjust my seat Eh We gamba No I think
it's fine I think we can save our materials for weapons and
such But now, what's abilities?
Oh!
There's not a skilled tree.
A skill line?
Plus 10 to energy.
Plus 25 to launch damage.
Yoink.
And.
Skill bush.
Skill columns.
Yes, yes, yes.
Uh...
Yoink.
What's this now?
Oh, additional weapon form slot.
Let's go.
Launch grenades and rockets back at enemy!
So when people were telling me that that's what I needed to
do when those guys with the homing missiles, I didn't even
have the ability to do it!
I didn't even have the ability!
You have to unlock that!
you're trying to get every newbie killed you know that skill
ladders are most thrilling you know this is why this is you
know like you can give as much a bit as much advice to a
person but when you play a game for so long you get used to
all the unlocks and things that you already have so that you
don't even remember that that was something that you
unlocked you just instinctively think Oh, you had to unlock
it.
Minus 50, trust in chat.
Sounds like a skill issue.
It is.
Board countermeasures.
What is this?
Kill, charge, using charge, kill enemies in the executive
sector.
What will you do when he does not awake?
Use spin arrow needles to make their enemies.
huh oh they're challenges kill enemies in the executive
sector kill enemies in the serve okay so if i kill oh so
they're side quests got it got it got it um i okay so that's
maybe maybe the door i don't think the door is open yet this
one's not open either so there's to do.
And I was going to check this.
The shatter.
And then we'll, um, let's see.
Projectile spread?
Recoil?
Damage against enemy armor plus 40.
Damage while low health plus 30.
Damage after kills.
Reload speed.
That was a good time to bring up that you can shoot your gun
without aiming down the sights.
Very useful for the shotgun form.
knew that, but at the same time, I just prefer it.
But I guess I'm faster without it, huh?
Without aiming down the sight.
So probably...
Thank you for the reminder, at the very least.
Wait, I can equip two guns?
We'll do the reload...
We'll do the enemy armor.
All right.
Missions, fine arti.
And the hotline.
What is this?
We are at war, hostile takeover.
The Hiss is the opposing force, foreign power.
We will provide countermeasures, strategies, except ingest
them at control points these countermeasures missions will
benefit you we will give resources rewards for each
completed countermeasure oh those are like the side ops okay
okay board whatever you say how do I change weapon though oh
switch weapon form okay okay good to know I
hear people talk
I know it's a
shotgun, dang it.
I need you to come up here, please.
Or something.
Oh, dang it.
Oh, I think he is coming up here, actually.
There he goes.
I know there's more of you.
Are there?
More of you?
Oh.
Oh shoot!
Ah!
Oh my god, please!
I need your health immediately.
I need health.
Thank you.
We're down here, maybe.
Right there.
Anybody else?
Health boost.
Yes, there's somebody else.
Oh, where?
Where are you?
Oh, nice.
Yeah.
Okay.
Anything else around here?
Special sounds.
Ammosphere in this game is so fun.
I just, like, exploded there.
I think there was, like, a big guy, a big explodey barrel or
something.
And I tanked it.
Those hits are so satisfying.
They are.
What is this?
We like launch efficiency.
Okay, so we got two new things.
We got launch efficiency, launch energy cost.
Health boost.
I have a health boost of 25, so this is not as good.
Energy boost.
Yeah.
I have accidentally explode myself with launch at times, so
yeah, it can happen.
I mean, when you're in the thick of it, you're just going to
be going for it, you know?
Is this a loop?
Or...
Yes, it is.
That's a level four, clearance.
I...
Um...
Don't know where I need to go.
Oh!
Just kidding.
Janitor's office.
I hear something.
What's down that way?
Hold on.
hold on he is coming from this way do we really want to go
this way a merry chase what does that mean what does a man i
think i i think i got the i think i activated it this place
makes me nauseous i think i activated the uh oh shoot the
mission on accident
An object of power.
How do you think it got down here?
Merry gore.
A carousel horse.
Why is this kid stuff always so creepy?
Why is it creepy?
What do you mean it's creepy?
Cleanse.
Be free by horse.
Umah, umah, umah, umah.
Be clean.
I'm the janitor of your soul.
to evade?
What am I evading?
Oh gosh.
Dash.
Oh, please open up.
Please open up.
Oh.
Okay, they're just kidding.
Oh,
can I like oh yeah whoa who are you
fine oh we're
fine don't worry about it gold enemies are immune to jesse's
attacks okay uh oh then what do i do i guys just gotta run
yeah i got school i got I smushed a little bit.
Uh, yeah.
Oh, more.
Let's see the hiss keep up with me now.
Now I can the- whoa, okay.
I got a new ability!
Woo!
Wait!
Please don't let me forget about it next week.
Oh, oh, it's a good thing there was a wall here.
Oh, is there a way to get up?
Is there a way?
Oh.
We'll remind you.
Yes, please do.
Oh, I cannot say anything.
It's so bright.
Ah!
Don't forget to die next week, Minky.
Thank you.
Hidden location discovered.
Wait, so like...
Was that the Mary Chase thing that was asking if I wanted to
be...
Like what was prompting me for?
In this economy?
We tell ourselves to be old.
What?
Oh, it's a side mission, so you can completely avoid it.
Very interesting.
I'm part Uma forever now.
Oh!
My bad eyes.
Oh my gosh.
I just caused...
I caused damage wherever I go.
I can't help it.
I can't help it with these arms!
Good to go for the side mission, powers.
Good to know.
Okay, so this looks like his room.
What's in here first?
Oh,
it pays to explore, baby!
Handle with care, huh?
What about these?
Yeah.
Oh, nothing escapes my...
My hands.
well done there's always like a puddle underneath you huh
it's place for congratulations yippee satana yippee it
happened in the last drop i truly need an assistant i'm the
director i've been a janitor i'm more at home in that role
than is the director only ati here seems to see that yeah hi
ati look we need to get the lockdown lifted otherwise i
can't get to the other sectors can you help me get to the
override yes yes easy peasy easy peasy it's just around the
corner but it's but first we need to get you working yeah
very small couple of hours job something tells me it's gonna
be more than that you think there's a dog breed in this I
can tell you are not the yesterday's Krause's son that's why
you'll make a great assistant cleaning sim time let's go
I'll hit the facts on the imagine like the entire game
changes this house has a vermin problem a bad one oh yeah
i've noticed messed up the cooling pumps that might have
been me power generators of power plant berkele and the
pensioner inside he's starting to feel the when you're
sweeping the situation needs to be fixed before the plant
blows up and we all disappear
trying my best to keep up with this yeah fix the coolant
pumps and the power generators otherwise the power plant
will blow but don't you worry i've left you clear
instructions i like jesse you'll catch the end of the thread
before i go to my vacation the works on the task board here
you can do later when you have time okay vacation right
Noah's gonna cancel my holiday, or Seed's gonna rattle.
But don't worry at all.
You'll take care of it, and soon this crisis gonna be last
winter snow.
You better go now, so you don't have to run with your head
as your third leg.
What does that mean?
The door in the back leads to the plant.
Okay.
The door in the back.
Clearance level two!
That's great.
Thank you, Atee.
Yeah, he's given the director orders.
His life is in your hands.
Travel Finland!
Wow.
This guy always is mopping up a puddle, though.
Like, again, perpetual puddle underneath him.
What is this now?
What a mess.
Burn the trash.
Yep.
burn the trash burn the trash in the fire is it easy burn it
all burn it into a reindeer not into a moose what does that
mean huh
i'm curious burn the trash around the furnace jesse helps
ati by burning the trash piled up around the furnish.
Do we do it?
Where do we...
It's time for coffee break soon.
Wait, where is it at, though?
I want...
I clicked to track it, but I don't actually know where to
go.
The map.
Oh, you're so right.
Oh, it's kind of far.
Or, I don't even know how to get there.
Wait.
There's, like, a mysterious, like, scraggly pathway that
looks like a like a mole man tunnel underneath the ground or
something that leads to the furnace oh i think you go there
anyway on the way to the primary quest oh okay well i guess
we'll see there was hold on they don't appreciate good music
you're so right there wasn't no sorry the door i was
thinking of over here was clearance for so we'll just keep
going
appreciate good music so where are we now okay spooky ah
this opens oh okay home at last good luck with cat plus
villain thank you welcome home okay this is just a big old
loop for if okay
What gun do I have right now?
There we go.
Okay, so what happens again if that thing blows up?
Power.
Explosion.
Oh my god, I thought somebody was walking there.
Too much.
Destroy everybody?
New York?
Bye-bye, New York?
Keep the lights on.
Okay.
What did I grab?
Evade energy cost?
Whoa!
Huh.
Okay.
Not as good as my rare, but...
More materials.
Collectibles.
The merry-go-round!
Yeah.
Hotline.
Okay.
Wait.
Oh, my bad.
Was I supposed to watch that?
was it this way better before wary than after was director
before me I never wanted his job I never wanted power I
purposefully avoided it didn't trust it didn't want to rely
on it Northmore was all about power a man like an explosion
hungry for authority fight Northmore maybe for more or so it
was too maybe he'll be like the next boss after find a
solution in the end Tulsi guy or whatever his name is the
situation Northmore never liked me but he went along he
didn't really have a choice smiley faces a director's most
basic duty is to keep the lights on here's to you Northmore
there were no prime cast it's waiting in the wings but i was
there hadn't been the whole time keeping my head down
working my ass off it's my sad face no i picked up the gun
almost on a dare
oh i was like it's so red in here it's blinding
This feels a little frightening.
Very final.
I don't like it.
What's this?
Arish?
Attention maintenance staff.
An object of power escaped the Penopticon a couple weeks
ago, and they want everyone to keep an eye on it.
Oh, if anyone sees a merry-go-round, horse zipping around
the sector alert me immediately do not try to contain it on
your own and definitely don't bind it to yourself your
security chief Simon Arish well I'm the director so it's
fine if it's to me right what are these guys oh they're like
little oh nice they're like little buggies anything else no
doesn't seem like it okay I'm the director it's fine
probably
Good guy?
Evil guy?
With a gun?
I can't tell.
Friend or fall?
Friend?
You see me, you see me.
You see me?
You want to shoot me?
Check out this moose.
You'll never want to touch me.
Maybe we're fine.
Hello.
It's dangerous out here, lady.
Go see Chief Arish.
He's just inside.
He'll help you.
Arish.
Oh.
Thank you.
Okay.
Um, I will actually set back our mission, I suppose, to
this, and we'll figure this out sometime again, I guess.
Hey, lady.
Um, don't call me lady.
Excuse me, I'm your boss!
Oh, I was hoping I could, like, hide in there or something.
I'm your boss.
Don't call me lady.
Go talk with Chief Arisha, the security.
He's in charge here.
I pay Arisha's paycheck.
Boss lady.
The satellites are so cool.
Hello.
Are you going to call me Lady also?
Uh, I hear whispering.
Oh, there's one.
So there are some floaty people around here.
Just yapp-yapping away.
They'd be perfect straight.
You know what?
The people that are floating and yappyapping remind me of,
like, when weird bots come into my chat and just say
nonsense.
I've never been able to take spooky, powerful objects
seriously in any gritty setting.
To me they're all Shang Gong Wu from Xiaolin Showdown.
I've not heard thought of that show in a million years.
I'm here to say nonsense.
I'm just looking around a bit.
Coolant pumps.
But I'm guessing I can't go through.
Okay, so you don't have to be rude about it.
Jeez.
I was just looking.
I'm golly I'm so angry for what reason
this is a pretty big room huh
I don't see like any files or nothing this is where I came
from yeah okay coolant pumps, energy, converters, central
maintenance and control room yeah they're not cool with me I
haven't passed the vibe check yet hello
Oh, there's one.
Oh, there's a couple.
Whole party over here.
All right.
I'm done looking around.
Let's go.
Security.
Hey.
Chief of Reach.
FPC security.
Should you be in a safe room?
Hold on.
I got stuff to read.
I'm a nerd.
Hey, Simon, I got your message.
Yeah, if someone in the sector is...
asking about Atee, just tell him you'll handle it and leave
it at that.
Under no circumstances should any personnel intervene with
his day-to-day routine.
Atee is like OP, this guy.
Nobody, he's the secret director.
I told you everything I know about him so you could better
deal with his odd habits, but yes, it's still very much a
classified matter.
Also, I saw your report about the quarry worker who wandered
into the foundation.
Detaining him was the right move.
We'll figure out what he saw before we decide on next steps.
Cheers, Lynn.
P.S.
at Casey to notice something is up between trench and
darling i know this isn't your strong suit but try your best
to stay out of it the scale of this place always makes me
think of aperture science lab it's always right yeah i'm his
new assistant you're right hello they all have hra's we're
on the same side my name is jesse faden i'm here to perform
the directorial override to get the lockdown lifted yeah
yeah chief irish fbc security i'm just well hang on you're
the new director um it's a pleasure ma'am let's skip the
formalities please right faden ma'am look as you can
probably tell oh my god we take his breath away we've been
holding our ground but whatever's gotten into our buddies
has them wrecking the coolant pumps and the power converters
oh no the nsc keeps overheating and my crews keep getting
shot before they have a chance to make any repairs no nsc oh
sorry bureau jargon it's what we call plant you know the big
rumbling metal thing he's got like sweat running down his
neck right now the dr. darling seemed to know what would be
a target darling he's here no it came down a few days ago
before everything went to hell he was out of it kind of
looks like an elephant he's ranting about vulnerabilities
and how he only had one large-scale HRA but that he needed
it somewhere else still at least he gave us these personal
HRAs before he left hey did I mention that he was tearing
his clothes off crazy dude darling knew the hiss was coming
listen i love playing 20 questions as much as the next guy
but we have got to get the water you have that effect on
people i'll have my guys unlock the doors out of here for
you thanks i'll take care of it you stay and keep the hiss
away from the plant if you can the hiss that's what we're
calling it that's catchy why it is a strange name so if you
find my boss salvador out there could you please ask him
what I'm sure he will have one by now.
I'll keep an eye out for him.
He sure has a lot of faith in his boss.
Try to stay alive.
Okay, fix the coolant pumps.
And fix the energy converters.
Now...
Now I'm an engineer.
Oh my gosh.
You ever have one of those itches that's like inside your
foot?
Oh my god.
women
in stem all right oh my god they suck right oh my gosh
okay what should we do first i guess i know where the pumps
are so i'm neighbors
Oh my gosh.
What the hell is that?
Holy.
Oh my god.
I have one HP in a dream.
Holy cow.
Oh my gosh.
I guess they're exploding now.
Yeah.
That's awesome.
That's really cool.
Is that why the door was so angry?
No.
Wait, are they exploding?
Are they exploding on the other side?
Are they, like, killing people over there?
Do I need to be doing something?
I guess it's fine.
Oh.
Is that an explosion?
I can't tell.
Don't control points fully heal you, does it?
Because if so, huge.
Let's try it out.
Great time to try it out, huh?
Oh, it does!
Let's go.
Wait, I have three more things.
I don't know how I got them, but...
Let's see.
I will...
50% damage.
10% melee damage.
20% energy.
I will unlock the launch explosives.
Maybe 10% health.
Okay, there we go.
That's good.
Oh, I don't really like these guys at all.
Okay.
Yeah, now we can grab the rockets and such.
Wee!
Oh.
This feels kind of bad.
Oh, what's in here?
Please be a little nicer than out there.
We got a ritual impulse material.
Cool, cool, cool, cool.
Okay.
It sounds like they're behind me.
So it's like freaking me out.
Oh, no.
Am I locked in a room?
Oh,
no.
Oh, you know, I am actually close to...
Wait, replace the parts.
Nani?
Oh, I need a thing.
I need this thing.
But how do I just lift it?
How do I just let it go?
Ah, oh.
Gamer, looko?
Ah!
Thank you.
I thought this one needed something to...
Oh, oh, I see how they are.
Thanks for the hint.
I'm so nervous.
Holy cow.
I'm nervous.
I'm so nervous.
Oh.
throwing grenades at me now.
Oh my gosh.
Ah!
I'm trying to shoot!
Okay.
Oh my god.
My ammo.
Okay, we're almost there.
Oh, shoot.
I did not mean to jump down here, but that's okay.
Maybe.
Maybe it's fine.
Screw your eye frames.
Yeah.
We took them out.
Run!
Clear the place!
Yes.
Very nice.
Oh, yeah.
Nice.
Okay.
And we're full health now and whoa.
What's over here first?
We have coolant pumps.
Oh, wait.
The furnace!
Oh, this is where we're supposed to do the other mission!
This one!
Right?
It's right here?
Yes!
Let's do the furnace.
What do you need?
Burn the trash.
It's not that, right?
We're taking out the trash.
Is this a trash?
My name is Dr. Pierce.
Lead researcher of the paraconeousiology department.
Huh?
I believe that I've discovered a code omega paranatural
entity.
Code omega!
It's your mom.
Darling refused to allocate me the budget or resources so.
So I'm taking matters into my own hands.
Let this recording be the proof I need to convince you.
The furnace can speak.
It's been talking to me for some time now.
Listen,
it's a sentient force capable of communicating.
I checked, and there's no record of ever installing this
furnace.
I believe it... Oh, sorry.
What?
Huh?
Yes, I can find you.
What do you mean?
Oh, feed me Seymour.
I'll try to find some volunteers.
Volunteers?
What are we, what are we burning the trash?
What kind of, that must be the trash, right?
All of these, right?
I guess it's worth a shot.
By a trash, did Atene barrels full of hazardous biological
material?
So close.
Volunteers.
Oh my gosh, it's so bright.
It seems like they're breaking some environmental
regulations on waste disposal.
But if that's what Aughty wants, then I'll give it to him.
The furnace feeds.
It's hungry.
Hungry for...
biohazardous material.
My eyes.
You're telling me.
Hello, Audrey.
Yeah.
This is just a strange version of Little Shop of Hours, for
sure.
Um.
Oh, there's stuff down here.
Okay, I guess we'll...
Oof.
Not bad.
Spit rate of fire boost.
now how do i get back up this is why i didn't come down here
oh there's some stair oh but there's also material mail tube
complaint hey bozo oh bozer oh my god get the get this the
accounting department still says they haven't received my
why did i read bozo oh my my expense reports the receipts
probably got lost in the mail tubes because of a shift or a
threshold of some some sort of uh freakery that if i don't
have the originals they can't verify my expense for
reimbursement this is such bs why do we even use these
freaking tubes if they just spit our mail out in some other
goddamn dimension just venting here before i make a formal
complaint useless pieces of rodriguez oh bozo El Bozo.
I think there's one right here.
Yes, indeed.
Probably said Bozo and right in the...
The Bozo.
The Bo-Zone.
Alright, seems like...
That's fine.
Seems like maybe there's one more or something?
Aha.
How far can my reach reach?
Oh, reach!
My reach reach!
Taking out the trash!
Seems I did get injured by one of them, though, so I'll go
reheal at the checkpoint before we go to the next area.
No, there's more?
That's a reach.
Where could the last one be?
Or not last, more maybe?
There's also health around here.
I'll just grab this, actually.
Okay, good.
Do you guys see any more?
I don't see any more.
Under the fan?
What about the fan?
Downstairs, one more.
Okay.
I'm searching.
I'm using my eyes.
My special eyes.
Oh!
Wait.
I see.
It looked like it was shining green for a second on that
metal.
Uh.
There's more fans.
Okay.
I don't see any more down here.
Use the force, Minto.
Like in here?
Oh, that's not what I meant to do.
Like...
No.
Other fight?
Oh!
Oh, how am I supposed to get over there?
Oh, wait.
Oh, I see it.
There we go.
Don't do that.
Nice thing you played one of my favorites.
As a friend, I do have my own cow in the ditch.
Thank you!
Thanks for the super chat!
Yay!
We burned the trash!
Oh, we got some... Oh, nice.
We got some more stuff.
Let's go.
Oh, my gosh.
I didn't mean to do that either.
Fireworks!
Wait, but there's like a door up there.
Hmm, very interesting.
Wonderful.
Somehow find our way back into here at some point.
game thank you thank you see you why are these in the air
like that funny okay hold on launch basic enemies when their
health is low oh that's and then we can do large enemies
then we could do large objects okay nice and we got oh
whoops more weapon forms maybe we still haven't sufficient
material sad that's fine all right to the next place where
does this even lead us to oh the coolant pumps and other
things i guess
okay little confused I don't like that sound me neither mold
what is this why oh wait it's I
think the texture are being funny.
No.
Yeah, it's definitely not pulsating.
Okay.
Hey!
Oh, my bad.
Oops, my bad.
Oh!
Can I grab their health?
Oh, there's more guys down here, huh?
Best be ready for them.
Oh, shoot.
Where are you?
Kill 50 enemies with the launch ability.
Oh, I'll do it again, too.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, my bad.
I mean, not sorry, but...
Did you leave any health?
No?
You shouldn't have tested me.
Oh.
That was kind of freaky.
Whoa!
Coolant pumps!
Okay.
Everybody be chanting.
Oh.
Go to city.
Fix it fast.
If the plant calls pool, we can throw the spoon in the coal.
Okay, so these guys, okay.
We need more of those things, no?
There's one down there on a power thing.
They're all over on power things.
We need to fix a power thing.
I don't even know what throwing a spoon in the corner will
do.
What's this?
Clawed complaint.
Oh.
Sometimes I press G instead of holding it, so it like...
His charge.
Oh, sick!
Wait, so its weak points are its chest and its head?
That's funky.
That gross blockage down in the water system is back.
What the freak is it?
And where does it keep coming from?
And why the hell does Atee keep yelling nonsense at it?
He acts like he can understand, like it can understand him.
Gross blockage down in the water system.
So is that like the the moldy stuff?
Same as kicking the bucket.
Oh no!
These ideologies.
Yeah.
Of course he acts like we can understand him too.
I guess that's his brand of crazy.
I'm gonna try out a new drain cleaner, extreme strength.
Yes, the drain cleaner of extreme strength.
That'll help the, uh, paranormal.
I think we need it.
One here, it seems.
Okay.
Uh.
Gosh, all this talking really just...
Can I have a moment's silence, please?
Alright, that one's being worked on.
This feels like a boss area, no?
I'm nervous.
Oh!
Nope, just kidding.
Before he gave me one.
Now I can't find it.
You can use any power cube.
But aren't they, like, working?
Are these not, like, their job?
Like, are they supposed to stay there is what I'm trying to
say.
My old enemy, the clock is...
Oh,
there's spares!
Oh, okay.
This?
Oh my gosh.
Holy cow.
That did a lot of...
Oh my gosh.
That hurt a lot, actually.
The clog is kind of crazy.
Woo!
Oh, gross.
Is it easier to shoot?
I mean, let's try it.
I guess so.
Is it dead?
What the hell is that?
That's the most disgusting thing I've ever seen.
This is the thing that we expected the drain cleaner to...
To take care of.
That's good.
Okay, anyway, shouldn't we be working on this?
Oh, Nass.
I caused a bit of a mess, guys.
My bad.
Okay, so I take one of these.
And I...
Did this have one?
If so, I didn't notice.
But I did see that one.
We'll put in the one that I did see.
DD Mega Doodoo.
Real.
This place is so...
Maze.
I'm just looking around, seeing if I can put it in anything,
you know?
Does this require one?
Doesn't seem like it.
But we know that required one.
Oh my god.
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run,
run, run, run, run.
I don't think that worked.
Uh.
Yeah, get away from me.
Wait.
Oh, I'm on the wrong gun.
Knock him out.
One at a time.
It's all I can do.
There's a guy.
Oh, he's gone now.
Dang it.
I missed.
Can I grab him now?
Anybody else?
Where are you?
Yeah, you.
Oh.
Almost got him.
Oh my gosh.
My health is so low.
Oh, I gotta be real cautious.
I wish somebody would come up here, kind of, so I could kill
them and then absorb their strength.
But, um, seems we don't have that.
My gosh, my aim.
It's fine.
He was far away.
Um.
Come back here.
Ah!
There we go.
There was one other guy.
Oh, there's maybe... I see him.
I saw him.
Oh, word.
I'm too nervous to jump down because my health is so low.
Come on.
Let me kill you.
Yeah!
I don't know if that actually killed him or not.
I'm going to run, though, for the health.
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run for the health.
Run, run, run, run, run for the health.
Running, running, running, running, running, running,
running, running.
I think there's not so many guys left though.
I think it's fine to go down probably.
Or...
We could do that.
Oh, there's still more?
You.
How many more are there?
Was that it?
Yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum.
Yippee!
I don't know where I killed anybody else.
Where are you going to find health?
Wherever I took them out!
I think I got all of it though.
Unfortunately.
So now do I go through...
The nastiness?
This thing?
No, this is the pipe works.
Oh!
Okay, I need to do more.
more coolant pumps where we're oh here's one oh that doesn't
seem very good oh i i didn't mean to do that oh my god my
bad oopsie shit what now my old enemy the clock is blocking
the pipes you need to deal with that i did know he's very
clever he's trying to sneak in he caught him caught with his
hand in the fist
oh my gosh but i imagine there's one other pipe that i can
insert into because that was just one and the bar is not
like halfway full so i think we gotta do another just keep
it actually we'll keep it on the Another one for now.
Maybe on another...
Aha!
There it is.
Okay.
Oh, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot.
Ah!
I'm tearing it apart.
I don't care.
I don't care!
Tear it apart!
Oh, that's not what I meant to do.
I probably...
I might need that, actually.
Uh, it's fine.
It's dirty.
It's durable.
It's very durable.
that was scary um anybody down here uh anybody up there just
die already
oh shoot die
already die already
sometimes I can't tell what's on beyond and what's okay
we're fine
let's Let's go up there and grab some health.
Push em up.
Is there any?
She's doing it.
She's controlling.
All right, so now we did two out.
Okay, yeah, yeah.
Yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum.
Eat em up, eat em up, eat em up.
Little blue dots, little blue dots.
Eat em up, eat em up, eat em up, eat em up.
Where did I?
Did I come from over here?
No.
I came from a...
Oh.
Because I was going to try...
Well, I guess it's fine.
We're full health.
It's probably fine.
Jesse's telekinesis reminds me of how the possessed items
flew at Alan Wake.
Doesn't it?
Alright, so what's going on in...
What's this situation?
I don't quite like it.
Oh.
Ah!
Oh, sheesh.
Oh, sicko.
Oh my god.
It's a actual protruding butthole.
Really not a fan of this entire situation.
Disgusting.
I don't know how far it reaches, you know.
Oh my gosh.
I don't know how it...
Like, took me out, so...
Like, it took so much of my HP last time.
I hope this isn't the water where...
Drinking.
That would be really unfortunate.
It's a real shitty situation, guys.
Okay, nothing over here.
Oh my god.
Everything is just...
Everything is just vomiting everywhere.
It's horrible.
Just the coolant water, yeah, yeah.
Oh, there we go.
Really trying not to get hit here.
What the?
Hello?
Oh my god, please!
Clog's been fiber-maxing.
Not after Taco Bell!
No!
That's horrible!
That's horrible.
Oh, this is the one we saw earlier.
this
part's kind of silly
is it clear are we good to go I don't hear anything anymore
bad timing we need to hurry
okay okay
Who's here?
Who I'll give you a stern talking to.
Anybody?
Oh, oh no.
Uh oh.
Oh no, he's coming!
He's descending!
Oh no!
Who are you?
Tommy guys!
Am I doing any damage to you?
Oh gosh.
Oh
my god.
I'm so stupid.
Let's run.
I ran, like, right into his bullets.
Um.
Uh, how do I take care of you?
How do I take care of you?
Oh shoot.
Oh my gosh.
Run, run.
Run, run, run.
And he...
Oh, okay.
That doesn't work.
Or it does?
Just kidding.
Yeah!
Oh, he's really...
He's slow, but scary.
We can stop his, uh...
gun, too.
Okay.
This is not a great place to be, I think.
Ah!
Drop down.
Uh, where is he now?
My poor ankles.
It's okay.
We can tank it.
Where'd he go?
Is he stuck?
Yeah!
Take him out.
He was just a little confused.
Yeah!
Tell me a mistake, is that true?
In that capitalist America, you clean pipes with bullets.
All right.
That was not so bad.
He was extremely slow.
I think, though, if they add him to, like, the roster of
guys we'll be dealing with, it's not going to be so fun.
You know what I mean?
That's gonna be a little...
He's very tanky.
Do I go in here?
Oh, I can.
Where does this take me?
Oh.
I meant to look at the map.
Where does this take me?
And then...
The door...
Other door goes back to the Janner's office.
To be fair, anyone be concussed after all that.
Congrats on beating the boss is an FYI.
control and Alan Wake are in the same universe.
Yes, I know.
That's why I'm playing it before Alan Wake, too.
Mm-hmm.
Oh.
Whoops.
I saw what I meant to do.
Alright, now we just got the energy converters.
Okay.
Ooh, it's freaky seeing the people.
Oh, my God.
What a visual.
Ew, there's so many of them.
Yuck.
What was that?
Hey!
Why are you guys acting funny?
What's going on here?
Chill out!
Hey!
How many are there?
Where are you guys coming from?
Oh, shoot.
Shoot.
How many more are there?
Oh my gosh.
Hey.
Ooh, I'll let him get in.
Needle King, thank you!
Hey, hey, take some of these blue dots, they heal you.
Oh, whoa.
Coming from there, right?
You thought you were watching a clip?
Nah, I'm right here.
Whoa, doesn't that look like the shadow of a person with a
gun from far away?
It's kind of funny.
Oh, there's a shelter here.
Anybody in?
Hello?
Yeah, it is a pre-recorded stream because I'm actually out
getting muck.
No, I'm just kidding.
The temptation is real though.
You okay?
Eat those dots.
They're delicious.
Tastes like a blue raspberry.
Blockages in pipes C through F.
Is the clock back?
Now?
Yeah, I took care of it.
Adia's gonna be so pissed.
Am I pre-recorded?
You are, you are.
Ugh, that I get a stretch.
Feel free to give in any time now.
No, it's okay.
I'm having fun.
You've been staring at this for ages.
Are you confused?
The building gives up.
I haven't given up.
Though, as the director, I really think we should invest in
other light maybe like a little I don't know anything else
something that like oh yeah oh yeah do have enough for the
for have spin a generous magazine and high rate of fire best
use in control burst see the thing is is I really do like my
pistol yeah like I have some hue lights and like a little
bit of purple, some orange, a nice like sunset ambiance.
Spin.
Spin has a generous magazine, a high rate of fire.
I mean, maybe it's fine.
I don't know, I've been using this more.
Upgraded grip is nice.
Unlock the second mod slot and increase base weapon damage.
Hmm.
Pistol always suits you.
I always feel that too, you know, but I don't I don't know.
Especially because I used it more in those other rooms.
I'll think about it.
So now I'm going to the energy converter.
Let's go.
Ikimashou.
Oh.
What?
There's bad guys over here!
What are you doing?
Blocking the doors!
Hello?
Ah!
Oh shoot.
I think we took care of...
Who are
you?
I can use some backup over here!
Oh my gosh, please.
Stop moving.
Yeah.
It feels like the enemy, the only, I guess my biggest, not
biggest complaint, but like, a complaint is, like, the
enemies legitimately feel never-ending sometimes, where
it's, like, they actually just spawn out of thin air.
So you're like, oh my god.
Oh, you.
I'm fighting Evil Dash.
Actually, Is there a... Oh, here we go.
Maybe the giant door that says energy converters?
The giant sign that leads to the door?
Is there like any...
Any stuff to read?
I'm a nerd.
I wish to procure some knowledge.
This is kind of freaky though.
Look at the shadow of the guy.
Like on the thing.
Not non-stop, but they respawn almost all areas.
What is central...
Have I been here?
I have not.
Is there...
Oh.
I could if I feel like field training.
Thanks.
Hey.
Wow, this restroom is huge.
Is this for the ladies?
Why is the women's bathroom like five times bigger?
Haunted toilet.
This area...
Oh!
That's a...
We saw this in that vision.
I remember.
Oh, there's a...
They're just projecting the spooky sounds on the intercom.
Black rock processing according to...
Oh, what did I just open?
Oh, here we go.
The his trooper.
I don't like this guy.
Oh, his weak spot is like in between his neck.
Thresholds.
The oldest house is at place in flux.
appear with no warning.
What the threshold will contain is a question we can only
answer once it manifests.
Hanako-kun, is that you?
The wildly accepted theory is that thresholds or dimensions
vibrating on a redacted frequency, different from our own,
when these frequencies match, the threshold will manifest in
the oldest house, which acts as a threshold.
As a guy, I have to assume this is what all women's
bathrooms are like.
You'd be very wrong.
Others theorize thresholds how our parallel universes are
possibly our own reality at a different point in time.
Some believe our collection of altered materials affects the
house or attracts the thresholds.
We do know for certain that thresholds are not permanent.
Eventually their frequency will shift.
Some believe earth is just another threshold connected to
the oldest house which is actually rooted in some other
reality.
This reality of all impossible to disprove causes redacted
and those who learn of it So, is actively denied.
Where am I?
I'm just kind of...
Security check.
Sort of following my own thing, you know?
I'm just kind of exploring at this point.
Good defense!
Home safe tests.
Hold on.
Just he learns of another object of power, safe in a field
training obstacle course well let me read it safe power of
object can produce a barrier using objects or materials from
its immediate vicinity oh the best defense this is a later
area but you can explore yeah i'll just look around a little
bit bureau rangers were given permission to employ heavy
weaponry against a para-utilitarian bound to this object in
order to gauge the barriers to durability redacted and
redacted velocity ammunition were tested with redacted
results oh is it good why would you redact the results how
am i how is anybody how would anybody look at this oh great
yes i i am a researcher and i am reading over these these
reports and uh yes the results were redacted Perfect!
We learned so much.
Maybe it was too good.
It must be, right?
Testing will continue after redacted.
The safe object of power is clearly a viable candidate for
use in combat response scenarios.
Shall we do it?
I mean, you guys said it's good to do the mission, so...
Oh, I keep pressing M for map, because, you know, that just
kind of makes sense, but...
I'm having a really nice bath while watching this anyways
congrats on the new cat hope all goes well Joshua thank you
I did not get the cat yet but it's good how am I supposed to
get there though oh I always press the wrong thing sorry
guys missed the beginning of the stream so I might have
missed you talking about it but did you get new cat already
nope not yet I only went looking today I think I have a cat
that I would like to get but I am not sure yet um or rather
I don't have them yet so oh so he's not quite mine
open wait danger open pit is this it this must be it yeah
or maybe not
I'm quite literally in the void of the map.
What?
Why?
What did I do?
Oh, I think I had a thing.
I think I was holding onto a...
Onto a...
Oh my god.
Leave me alone.
Where did you guys come from?
You're destroying this room.
Oh.
He's stuck in there.
Ah!
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god.
I'm trying to leave.
I can't...
How many of these do you have?
I think he exploded himself.
Oh no, there's still more.
Where did you go from?
He's got a grenade launcher.
Tentem, thank you!
Where?
Oh my gosh.
All I did was explore a little bit.
I'm being punished for being curious.
Tennyson report- Oh, warning.
Listen, Trench is on the warpath about this Tennyson report
thing.
He wants to know who wrote it and he wants to know
yesterday.
Whoever did this is gonna get crucified.
I don't know if it was one of the guys, if it was one of you
guys, and I don't want to know.
I'm not super keen on leading a witch hunt, so tell everyone
in the sector to keep their heads down.
Best not to be on anyone's radar right now.
What is this report?
And it'll ruin the bathroom.
Not me!
Cat name ideas.
Huey for a boy, Naomi of a girl.
No!
He already has a name, and I like it.
So I'm keeping his name.
I tell you, not even counting all the weird sheesh we deal
with, this place can be a downright hostile work environment
sometimes.
I'm feeling very hostile.
I don't feel welcomed at all.
Can I even go through here?
No.
Clearance four.
How lame.
Oh, I guess I could go this way.
what's his name i'm not saying yeah because he's not i
haven't i don't if i don't get the cat then obviously that's
not going to be his name but they destroyed everything but i
like his name if i get the cat then his name will remain the
same that's all sector elevator i don't think we should go
there and then there's field training so we're just gonna
leave
and uh time to go over here
i'm not saying any details you guys why i already said that
i don't know if i'm even gonna get the cat because somebody
else might adopt him before me so why would i tell you about
the cat and then i don't can't even get him so i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna jinx it
Elevator.
All right, let's go this way.
Thank you for the bread!
Thank you, thank you, welcome, welcome!
I'm playing Control.
We need to fix this thing ASAP.
I almost said I'm playing Alan Wake.
Imagine.
Gun?
Oh, I had the right gun.
Hmm.
Oh, shoot.
Oh.
Hey, stop it!
I'm cleansing the point!
I saw the tweet, congrats on your new cat.
I don't have him yet!
Mold!
Maybe I shouldn't have tweeted anything.
Wait, can I pick up the mold?
Can I eat the mold?
Thanks for the gifted!
Delicious.
Oh, yeah, it did.
Okay, cool.
Mold, mold, mold.
It's fried up.
You need to fix it before the old twigbats inside the plant
has a shit.
Eh,
eh, eh, eh.
Before he even knows what hit him.
Can I get that guy up there?
Too tall?
Oh, nice hit!
This one's freaky too.
Ah!
Oh my god, please.
Like I saw.
Oh, I didn't see it.
Holy...
Where the
heck?
Like, actually, where did you go?
come from?
Let's go upstairs.
Oh, nice.
Thank you.
So proud of all your success, man.
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
She freaky!
I forgot you read French.
No!
Destroy the research.
I guess there's nothing up here, though.
Okay.
We continue on.
forward?
Oh,
yeah.
Take them out, take them out!
Take them out!
Oh, let me change my gun.
Are we back to normal?
Maybe?
Kill, kill, kill!
We got...
Reload Efficiency.
I still have the plus health.
Let's see what...
What do we have?
Oh, I have another health boost, but not as rare.
Launch Efficiency.
I want more launch stuff.
Recovery Energy Speed.
So far, I still think...
Well, what else we have?
Reload Speed.
Exclusive to Shatter.
Oh, I didn't upgrade yet.
Damage boost.
Oh, we can just do a damage boost, I think.
On this one.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Shatter has, like, right now we have damage against enemy
armor.
Projectile spread.
Minus 12%.
Oh.
I'll just keep it as I have it right now.
Okay.
Oh,
dang it.
Come on.
Where'd they go?
Oh.
Oh, I'm trapped.
I'm in a not good spot.
Where'd they go anyway?
Hello?
Anybody?
Everybody?
Wait, was that you?
Oh.
Oh, come on.
Where'd you go?
Oh.
Oh, there's just two of them.
I don't know where I'm supposed to be going.
Oh, wait.
Oh, I see.
You into you.
Alright, we got one.
Did that make anybody come out?
Oh, open this door.
Nice.
I guess I'll take another.
I'm playing Portal now.
It feels like.
You.
there's so many guys well now i'm gonna look around and see
if there's any anything up here nothing it seems thinking
with portals i've been itching so bad for oh sheesh
uh but itching so bad for another like portal game there was
like a game that i saw that came out i can grab uh like the
other day and i was kind of excited for it was like some
like space game that says it's like combined a 2001 space
odyssey and like portal and like all these other vibes
portals and soup are made as well trade and i was like oh
man That sounds like so up my alley.
Let's go lift the lock down.
Yay, yay!
And I was waiting for like reviews on it.
The reviews seem mixed.
So I'm a little like, hmm.
Can I open this?
How do I get in there?
But, yeah.
Oh, that's how I get in there.
Yeah, I wish Valve kept making games too.
I wish they still made games.
Is there anything up here?
Besides people?
It's people!
Hallows Principle is a decent puzzle game like Portal, some
philosophical themes.
I see.
I mean, there's still obviously decent puzzle games that I
haven't...
I haven't had the chance to play yet.
But you know.
The vibes.
The vibes of Portal were so good.
My throat is still killing me.
I think puzzle games tend to be subject to harsher reviews.
I agree.
Because you have to be so clever.
You know?
Like.
If I were a game dev.
I would never make a puzzle game.
I would be too afraid to.
You know?
Because.
Like it is.
so they're so heavily scrutinized
upcoming game reminder next game is wednesday at eight or
usual spot hazard owes me 20 bucks a reach still on a
winning streak someone please figure out how he's cheating
thompson suspended for a game because of that shady dealing
incident guy i owe you 60 i brought beers last time so it's
hepson stall stern
start bouncing the difficulty is tough in those types of
games right hydration time yeah i'm gonna actually go grab
some more water i'll be right back i'll be right back right
back one second
we'll be back we'll be back we'll tell you how we're gonna
make it happen let's take a ride spend our day in the
countryside I'm back?
Welcome back, thank you.
Okay.
Have you ever played Dead Space?
No!
Actually, I have it on my list of games to play next month.
I want to start it, I want to start it.
Dead Space, finally.
Electricity level?
Max.
Water level?
Clean.
This doesn't look good.
Dad's space.
I'm scared.
This doesn't look good.
Investigate the training course.
Is that this place?
You want me to go all the way over there?
Hmm.
Mint is going to make us whole.
Is that a dead space really?
reference oh wait that's the that's the oh i keep pressing
sorry i keep pressing escape um yes that is the side mission
yeah i guess we're supposed to go in there oh man this oh
what is this unless
unless i just leave
If you play Dead Space 3, you should play co-op with
someone.
It's better than doing it solo.
Yeah, that'd be fun.
Okay, let's just go.
I'm nevish, but we'll get it, maybe.
I don't know.
Seems pretty bad.
Yeah.
Oh my god, my aim!
Ah!
Yeah, get on both.
Oh.
Control!
Cleanse!
Just got my Midsantam Goatap for the dessert.
Thank you, Equals!
Thank you for ordering it.
Yeah, okay.
That wasn't so bad.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh.
Forces contain the lockdowns.
Only be lifted by a directorial override.
That's what I'm gonna do.
This is what we came here to do.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, let's watch these.
So much is expected from the director.
The responsibility, the privilege, to steer the Bureau into
dangerous waters and safely out again.
Oh.
inspire and lead its people to protect the same page the
board is there to advise you but they want things in return
i feel like we're seeing more of his face in this room you
hold all this in your old trembling hands my trembling hands
i had to lose everything before i could see the bureau is
the director's life there's no room for anything else if the
forces contained here escaped we'd back into an age of
superstition superstition that's kind of fun assuming you
think we ever really left that behind but that's not for
black cats any major containment breach and the lockdown
goes into effect you guys are you guys superstitious I
implemented this security measure in my first years as
director I don't mind I've opened umbrellas and doors maybe
that's why I'm unlucky sometimes see the cost of sloppiness
i made sure the internal lockdown could only be lifted by a
directorial over a little there's some that i'm like
superstitious about and some that i'm not you know the
sectors are safe to be opened again this way i only believe
in ghosts as you showed and if i screw up it's on me and me
yeah i'm a little stitious a little cishus not superstitious
What's in your multimedia game?
Oh, the recordings.
Okay, yeah, yeah.
Anything else in here that we should grab before we
override?
Anything, anything, anything.
Health, I don't...
Oh.
Nice.
Spin grouping efficiency.
I think we're good, then.
Little stuff.
Whoa!
The gun reminds me of the gun from that one anime.
Oh, shoot.
Psychopaths, yes.
That's your giant plushie.
He keeps finding these cardboard boxes to hide under.
Cool.
That's it.
The other sector should be open now.
All right.
I think it's time I told Emily why I'm here.
For the biscuit.
You two should get to know each other.
Screw that.
Beat Emily.
I don't know her.
That's what the voice is saying.
Where are we?
Oh, up here.
Okay.
I want more than a biscuit if I'm gonna risk it.
Don't be greedy now.
Wait a second.
Where am I?
I know I can.
I know that I can fast travel.
But I'm trying to get a little bit of a way of the land.
Ah!
Where am I?
Where do I need to go?
Not the power plant.
The...
Where?
Central executive.
That's where I need to go.
The side quest.
Yes, that is a thing.
There's dots, so you killed some people.
You lose 10% of your source every time you die.
Wait, what does that mean?
What does that mean?
What?
Game?
Are you alone?
Okay, here we go.
We absolutely noped out of there.
I want to see, is it still, like, red?
We were in somewhere.
The, um, this was...
I wonder if we can, like, fast pass, fast, fast travel to
that.
I guess it would be here would be the closest.
Actually, I have no idea how these work.
I don't...
Can we even...
get there?
I've never been there.
Fast pass.
I'm so theme park brain, man.
Wait, I'm reading it, right?
Am I?
If I I almost said fast pass again.
If I fast travel to here, so I'm guessing this takes me down
here and then boom boom?
I'm guessing?
you are a disney girl the worst part is is that they have
not used fast passes in like many many many many years um
yeah okay wait let's talk to emily first emily has asked us
to document his incantation as she calls it you mean like in
person in person with a pencil and paper oh she's trying to
get us killed they're incantation they're just speaking I've
talked to them doesn't it change the lightning pass now yeah
something like that just the lightning lane or whatever you
lifted the internal lockdown I did let's talk Emily yes of
course doesn't anybody else when someone's like hey can we
talk can we talk that gives you the most anxiety ever I know
it's not just me listen Emily but anybody else in chat screw
it just tell her I haven't been completely honest I have a
younger brother Dylan when we were kids we found an old
slide projector in ordinary's landfill the slides created
doorways to other places I've been wondering what they what
happened bad things happened oh bad things happened came
through oh that's all she gets bad things came through the
rest stays locked inside okay but we found help through one
of the doorways we met something a being a being a being
what kind of being it's hard to describe but it she helped
us she we managed to turn the projector off the bad things
that came through the doorways we're gone okay after that
your people came tried to grab us oh I ran away your brother
they got Dylan yeah I left him behind oh bureau agents took
your brother yes he covered it up wait so they never give
him back believe me they can't like men in black and you
know i'm i've been looking for him ever since what happened
to this slide projector it sounds like another object of
power i imagine you they took it i thought you took it the
bureau along with dylan no i've never heard of it but around
Assume everything's classified.
Uh-huh.
I looked into the ordinary AWE case files after you
mentioned it.
Trench and Darling were both involved.
A large area of the containment sector was reserved for it.
The case hasn't been active for a long time.
I have no idea if anything's still there.
Oh.
Can you tell me more about this being you found?
Let's hope you two get along.
Oh my god, wait.
She's been with me ever since ordinary.
in my head Zach she led me to you I call her Polaris Polaris
as in a guiding star did Polaris know about the hiss if she
got you in here in spite of the lockdown she's very powerful
Zalaris may help explain your test results your Jesse now
cross-referencing them with the database.
I found two matches and Darling's old classified files.
Unfortunately, I can't access them beyond the file codes,
but one was P6 referring to a prime candidate for a
potential future bureau director This was logged years ago.
Whoa Dylan.
Is that Dylan?
The other match is on something called Hedron, which must be
connected to these Hedron resonance amplifiers somehow
Marshall went to the research sector to secure the HRA
production after his first attacked.
So, Marshall seems like our best lead on Dylan.
I need to go after her.
How can I get to the research sector?
Use my key card.
Oh!
Yeah, clearance three, baby!
Marshall is the next step.
What Emily told me about ordinary, my powers being connected
to things in the Bureau's past, I am so close to something.
Do you feel it?
Something's coming.
I feel it, I feel it, actually.
I feel it.
We take turns to come for a visit.
I helped you.
You owe me now.
And when time comes, I will come calling.
And I've been talking now.
Wait, auntie, what do you mean?
I helped you.
I took out the trash.
Wait, that sounds really ominous.
Wait, auntie?
Mickey, you should know my four-year-old niece was helping
with you.
Oh, was helping me.
And she went to my room with you on the monitor.
She froze still.
screen and yell she's so cute so you have four-year-old
approval oh sinister thank you oh tell your niece she's so
cute skeptic for now thank you good job thanks um i'm scared
find marshall old boys club pope informs jesse that marshall
went to the research sector to create more hras jesse
believes marshall may know more about dylan Is that a
countdown?
Go to the NSC Energy Converters.
Wait, is that a...
Is that a countdown?
It is?
Have you ever heard the song Disney Girls by The Beach Boys?
Pretty little melancholy song.
Maybe something you'd like.
I've never heard it.
I'll look it up.
Thanks, Abstract.
Time quests are optional.
Just combat.
Are they, I mean, would you say they're like super worth it?
Or I don't want to like stress ourselves out, you know?
We got a new thing from the board though.
Oh, they're randomly generated for loot.
Okay.
They're all right.
Oh, the speakers, yes, yes!
Astral Plane is a Conflux switchboard.
The Hiss will come for us all.
You must stop, shut up them.
Okay.
Okay, I'm working on it.
What do you want me to do?
I'm working on it.
Um.
What did you say?
Uh.
The good defense.
I do still.
want to check out this one because i'm assuming it means
i'll be able to like pick up objects and like use them as a
shield which is pretty cool too brings up a lot of new
questions you we chat watch what about the plant attracted
them the power plan is largely confidential no use guessing
the his's motives if we don't even know what kind of energy
uses yeah shut them up shut up you guys shut up everybody
stop talking right so oh wait we have now more abilities
let's see launch large enemies yeah i think though i'm gonna
do more health oh no i can't do more health and more launch
damage that sucks i need to use melee more huh i mean i
don't need to but you know what i mean um
why does the more health have to be three shield power is
really good Melee is good if like a guy sneaks up on me or
something you know Energy is always worth yeah Energy is
always worth too Ah
Which do I upgrade?
Because I can only upgrade one I mean I could upgrade this
and the large enemies But I do Okay I'm gonna do this I will
upgrade this And the large enemies And then i will next time
do let's say we get like like four again and then i'll do
health or something and or energy energy is also really
important because we we need it we need we need the we need
more energy to be able to launch things so yeah okay fast
travel let's take care of uh Defense?
Nantucka, nantucka, nantucka.
Shoot, I don't know where I needed to go.
Fast travel.
Okay, here we go.
To the control room and then run to central maintenance.
Take the elevator down or down, I'm guessing.
Elevator is quickest.
So, like, yeah, that's what I mean.
Like, basically I'm saying I go from here, go to the
elevator, and then that elevator takes me here.
No, I'm guessing.
And then the...
You can use the elevator in the central executive.
Wait, I can.
The central maintenance?
They say the major record is on the object.
Maintenance sector?
Okay.
Let's try.
Access corridor.
I don't know what that is.
Let's see.
I wish I had just activated the, uh...
I wish I had just activated the quest when I got it.
I should have done so.
That's okay.
Alright, where are we at?
Oh!
Actually, where are we?
We're back here.
Was it really over...
This way?
Can I go through here?
Wait, how do I get through this?
I mean, though, I finally have all three of my big Vito
plushies, and they're so big.
Oh my gosh, can't control, thank you!
All of their sizes combined are almost as big as my love for
Vito.
Stub!
The red thing is shootable?
Thank you so much for the pink, too.
Thank you so much.
Oh, look around for red cubes.
Oh, like this.
Oh, this is new.
Oh, what?
Ah, there we go.
That takes care of him better.
Yeah, shut him up.
Shut him up.
Ah, okay, okay, nice, thank you guys.
That was new.
When in doubt, bonk your way through, baby.
What is this?
I'd like to file a formal complaint, read the unauthorized
use of my voice in a state of quality that I did not agree
on.
The fact that they were planning to use material from what I
thought was a rehearsal was not communicated to me at all
had it been i would have disallowed the use of those
recordings i want use of the ranger field training course
recorded messages to halt immediately i will not stand for
this humiliation among my peers i will go to hr of this with
this if necessary randall poloski i'm sure you sound
wonderful randall who are these guys oh my gosh A bunch of
stuffy guys and suits.
Yuck.
Anything here?
Complete the training course.
Welcome to the Ranger Field Training Course.
The course must be completed in the specified amount of
time.
When you're ready to start, press the button.
I always did love obstacle courses.
Okay.
Is this tough?
Ranger.
Course starting in five, four, three, two, one.
Go.
45 seconds remaining.
What?
Ah,
wait.
30 seconds remaining.
Wait, what am I supposed to do here?
Is there another one?
I don't know.
Uh, don't.
Oh, I'm not ready.
Oh my gosh, I need a freaking...
Uh...
Five seconds remaining.
No!
Horse failed.
I just barely made it.
Ah!
Okay, okay, I at least know it now.
Horse failed.
I was so close!
Horse starting in five.
I have to remember that shift is, or that sprint is toggle.
Oh,
I don't think I got it.
I think we'll get it this time, though.
Oh, my gosh.
Please.
Oh, I'm depleted.
Oh, my God.
How am I?
No, please, please.
Ah!
5 I made it!
Oh.
Guessing this isn't usually part of the course.
You need to hit it harder to break that shield.
Hit it harder.
It's protecting itself.
Ha!
Yeah!
First try.
The safe.
I absorb your power.
Wait, what am I, what do you want me to grab?
Hold Q to shield, okay.
Oh.
Whoa.
Interesting.
Oh.
Oh, I, oh, it's different than I thought.
Okay, interesting.
Ah, bread!
Oh!
Okay.
It will become a bit more useful with upgrades, yo.
Yeah, because we're pretty like slow at the moment,
unfortunately.
Maybe we're fine.
I'm stuck on a rock.
Go, go, go!
Yeah, I did notice it wasn't regenerating.
Yippee!
Ah!
Oh my god.
This is evil.
Oh, I can't.
Oh my god.
I'm running.
Ah!
Yeah, my shield dies.
Oh, well, they didn't tell me that I couldn't attack with
it.
No, I learned that now.
I learned that now.
I got meleeed.
Oh,
we're fine.
Okay, yay!
I easy mode out of it.
Guys, I actually just sped run the...
Yay, we can go back now.
Yahoo!
Back to...
research sector is where uh let's go back to the executive
sector real quick
you should be able to throw the shield like captain america
uh yeah i feel like maybe an upgrade that would be good was
you put up the shield and then you go like and it like
explodes and sends them all everywhere okay sorry i just
wanted to get my bearings here a little bit what's this
launch energy cost okay they have that okay that's what i
think i thought that they probably would have something like
that spain weapon armor damage oh well why wouldn't oh wait
damage against enemy armor wait
What's the difference between damage and damage against
enemy armor?
Is there any?
The screen tip basically said the shield rush ability is
exactly that.
Oh, that's funny.
Losey, welcome back.
Thank you so much for 26 months.
Cat deciding, maybe I want a pogger parent.
What does that mean?
Oh, the armor is the white bar.
Oh, gotcha, gotcha, gotcha, gotcha, gotcha, gotcha, gotcha,
gotcha, gotcha, gotcha, gotcha.
Yes, okay.
I knew that.
Because I knew that was what that was.
What collectibles do we got?
The home safe.
No unique procedures required.
The object is a guard house brand home safe.
Weight measurements vary.
When bound, the object allows peri-utilitarians to
telekinetically gather items and debris from their
surroundings.
didn't realize that like with the objects of power we would
be getting like more kind of abilities I think that's pretty
that's pretty nifty discovered in the basement of a home in
Ohio the object gained rapid interest in certain online
forums dedicated to opening abandoned safes wait that sounds
kind of awesome that sounds like kind of awesome after
months of failure the own owner attempted to open it with
explosives.
The objects survived with no physical damage.
Bureau agents were dispatched, now confident of its
paranatural nature.
Blood occasionally emerges from seam around the object's
door.
Test confirms the blood is not human.
X-rays taken of the object indicate that something is
trapped inside, though the images are always blurred, which
indicates the contents of the object are moving.
All attempts to open the object have been unsuccessful.
Actually, I don't think we read about the, oops,
merry-go-round.
The object was discovered at the site of an abandoned
amusement park.
Local, redacted, reported that the rides would move on their
own and that they would be chased out.
When these rumors reach the Bureau, see America Overnight
Episode 235, agents were dispatched to investigate.
Three local redacted were found dead at the scene.
The object attacked agent redacted by redacted.
Oh my god, not the agent getting redacted.
That's scandalous.
agents invoked formula c5 to redacted the object long enough
to redacted
it's like those people who buy a house and find an abandoned
find abandoned safes i've never heard of i mean it's like
i've never thought of that i've not i've never had the
thought of being like oh yeah the abandoned safes but like
it's so people will put anything inside of abandoned safes,
or like anything inside of safes, you know?
I've talked about the Winchester Mansion sometimes before,
but Sarah Winchester, she had a safe, obviously, I mean, she
had at least one safe, but there was a safe that was in a
room, that like, I think the room wasn't used except for
just having that safe in there, and nobody knew what until
like after she passed away and then eventually they were
able to find a way to open the safe and all that was inside
was a lock of hair from her deceased baby so
it's pretty sad but it's kind of one of those things where
it's like you never know what's gonna be inside a safe you
know nah
Thanks for the feel-good story, Minto.
Yeah, I got you.
I got you.
You can come here for some real funny stories.
We've never recorded any distance over five.
Obviously, you never read the P6 data.
P6?
Did you say P6?
Did you say the P6 data?
Okay, let's go to the research place.
Oh,
that's our mission.
Find Marshall.
Let's go.
Check the skill upgrades.
Oh, yeah, that's right.
I did have one.
I said I was going to do abilities.
We're going to do energy.
I will do energy and then I will do health.
Oh, wait.
I can do energy and then I can do large objects.
Wait, that's sick.
Yes.
Oh yeah.
Large objects.
Oh, wait, I have shield.
Oh, I already did it.
Oopsie.
Wait, let's see what we got.
When released, shield propels debris and nearby enemies!
100% to shield barrage damage.
while holding shield use evade to rush at enemies and knock
them back what the shield rush energy will recover while
shield is active oh that's huge too wait oh my gosh we want
we're gonna go to the shield route for sure and we got an
additional personal mod slot so that's neat um
Maybe we divert our...
We divert our stuff a little bit.
Containment sector.
I'll put in the request with Pope.
No, what personal mod?
Oh, here we go!
Nice!
Let's do like...
Rarity by rarity?
Health boost.
Wait, don't I...
I have the astral health boost.
health boost.
Oh, I can do another health boost.
Oh, launch energy cost.
We'll do that.
Operation PP poo poo.
Oh, yeah.
I found melee damage to be useless, but that's just me.
It was nice at first, I guess, you know, but you can
deconstruct.
Wait, you can deconstruct them?
Oh!
What?
You can.
Oh, deconstruct.
Deconstruct.
Heck yeah.
And I, yeah, I guess we have like a limited number of...
Honestly, I'm never gonna use the energy boost 5%.
Like, you know, like we could just get rid of that.
Health, 18%.
But we have another 8...
We have a 20%.
so the common ones i think we can just start getting rid of
to be honest like i even have the launch energy cost they'd
start getting worse yeah you do run out of space good to
know good to know i'm gonna keep that energy recovery speed
health boost we don't need and health pick health recovery
is we don't really need okay cool yeah nice now we're at 20
000 and uh wait um
astral constructs we can still get one
i'm thinking the i'm thinking this one i don't think i have
enough for both i think of maybe the pistol might be good
base weapon damage up sounds good yeah alright let's go for
it yippee and honestly we don't have that much to get so
that's alright alright cool we're like we're like we're
getting all our upgrades in we're getting all our stuff in
what's this reload speed I'm guessing there's yeah there's
awesome we can deconstruct these as well can't we yes we can
awesome then we'll do the rare one exclusive to spin we'll
do this one yeah I have damage up 15% is there anything else
that the headshot damage well
grip is good for the entire game with good aim honestly
really?
I know, right?
There's so many upgrades.
It's kind of insane.
Reload speed, we can get rid of...
Well...
We'll do...
Exclusive to speed.
I don't have a speed.
We'll do this one.
It's technically better.
Projectile spread.
Um...
I guess we'll have this for now.
I will deconstruct like some things.
Like...
Well, the repeats.
And the lower ones.
Ammo cost per shot.
Oh, yeah.
You're going to start finding some higher tier mods soon.
Don't worry, okay?
As long as you say so.
I'm going to go just a little bit while longer.
want to like at least look at the research sector since um
that'll be your next place to go baby oh yeah oh yeah oh
yeah good night mint have fun thank you good night armor
damage kind of dog since you burst them with telekinesis i
guess that's true right oh
oh oh whoa this
This place looks, like, kind of nice to work at, no?
Like, what a crazy-looking building.
Whoa.
Hi!
I'm Dr. Casper Darling, head of research.
Somebody thought this video would make for great internal
communications.
I'm looking at you, Mr. Tremasi.
I'll rest in peace.
This is where the magic happens.
Anyway, I've been here for years.
24 years now how humble i've always been here it's a little
nice little like a classroom we've made astonishing
discoveries authored studies of grave importance and in all
this work good luck with work thank you there's one thing we
know and that's how little we truly know true rest assured
we're committed to keep pushing the known laws and borders
of reality and to make the bureau proud so welcome assuming
you have the necessary clearance and and do follow the
safety protocols the manual.
Otherwise, bad things will happen.
Sometimes the Alan Wake really, really comes out, you know?
Research sector, huh?
Home of the Bureau's mad scientists.
Look, we gotta shut these people up.
Okay, we can't go in there.
Darling, my beloved.
I was talking with Limu about this game, too.
She also really likes Dr. Darling, so I'm interested in
learning more about him.
Plant complaint.
Hey, so I was wondering about the plants and research.
Is it really necessary to sing to them?
I mean, that janitor does have a nice voice and the plants
sure seem to like it.
Maybe he could just switch it up a bit.
I'm getting pretty tired of the tango.
And where did these plants even come from?
No one seems to remember when they were planted.
People like them a bit too much if you ask me.
Are we being invaded by houseplants?
Worth looking into.
Dr. Lewis.
Alright.
what does this say some shoebox notes some notes i think
i've stumbled into something here only oh only notes early
hypothesis now further tests needed shoebox retrieved from
ordinary summer 2012 potential altered item not flagged awe
and lab everything what's going on in ordinary This place is
anything but...
This place is anything but...
Samantha Wells.
Repopulation ongoing.
Repopulation?
Shoeboxes can't be altered.
Content safe.
Why?
How a loophole?
We could use this.
Who took the shoebox?
We are in the middle of a test here.
Bring it back.
Idiots.
Named it ironically.
Truly.
What the...
Oh.
Is that a floaty person or a standy person?
Wow, these trees are aww.
Gosh, dang it.
These are the guys that can't...
Oh, yeah, they avoid.
They avoid.
I remember.
There we go.
I need... Oh.
Destroy?
Oh.
Nobody's shooting at me.
I say that and they'll start shooting at me.
Oh, you guys so lucky mister.
Oops.
I thought I just...
Stop moving around.
Finally.
It's somebody.
Yeah!
Ah!
That's why they weren't shooting at me.
Oh my god.
There we go.
More guys in coming.
Ah!
Oh my god.
Oh, did I get...
Can they see me?
Can I see them?
Where are they?
I'm going down.
The old stealth rocket trick.
Yeah, for real.
Nah, nah, nah.
They're never ending, I'm telling you!
Leave me alone.
I'm your director.
Oh, there's another guy over there.
Yeah!
More!
Holy cow.
That's what I mean.
These areas that the enemies are just non-stop.
Oh, wait.
I have my shield now.
Oh, why did I do that?
Take that guy out.
Are you important or something?
Who are you?
Yeah.
There we go.
I think I missed a thing before too.
Is that everybody?
This guy had a name.
Yeah, it was special.
But one thing I am very grateful is that this game has
unlimited ammo.
I don't Surviving in survival horror is like Hellish for me,
you know Still?
I think Is the music calming down or what?
Yeah, inventory management And all Yeah Yeah, there's still
one more Somewhere I wonder, I think it's that floaty guy I
don't think I killed him Yeah I think he's still around
somewhere.
Oh, I guess I did pick it up.
What's over here?
Did I explore this part?
Oh.
My show!
Excuse me!
What is that?
That's a bed.
That's not the motel, is it?
out of the way doc oh look how cute
sir could you please move sir i'm trying to watch my soaps
where did that guy go i know i didn't kill the other one
unless like something exploded in there and got them both
dr darling's office how exciting holy cow I'm so excited oh
my god let's go
I've been fielding questions recently regarding HRAs he
looks rough what are they for do you always need to wear
them and what's the deal with the headroom oh sorry what's
the deal
Despite what you may have heard HRAs are not monitoring
devices We're not tracking your movements Or listening to
your conversations Finger off the trigger It is, it is We do
that regardless Whether or not you're wearing An HRA Okay,
well Think of them as...
Thanks for telling me as a life preserver only instead of
water the the thing HRAs protect you from is classified
right one day that classified not water might pour in and
one day meaning like next week you'll be glad you got a got
an HRA keep me afloat and if you don't have an HRA don't
worry it'll be quick and painless
Kidding, it's not quick nor painless.
We're making more.
Oh.
Thank you, doctor.
Where is he?
Resonance theory.
Resonance, it's there, but we can't see it.
It vibrates around us, through us, from us.
But what if the vibration is conscious?
What could a force like that do?
Redacted open the door to a redacted.
I've called redacted.
Redacted.
The redacted emits a force that is far beyond the forces
we've previously dealt with.
It has shown me so much that I have to wonder.
Is resonance the key element in all altered phenomenon?
AWEs, altered items, objects of power.
Do they share a common redacted that we've yet to discover?
We can harmonize control points, but what else would the
correct frequency allow us to achieve?
What if resonance has been the answer the whole time, refer
to file redacted for follow-up one?
Whoa!
Collect 80 collectibles.
Dear Dr. Darling, I suspect my colleague Dr. Harrington has
already contacted you, asking for an increase in her
department's budget?
I'm not surprised.
Parapsychology has always been the squeaky wheel, all fuss
but no results.
Parakins...
Wait, how do you say this?
Parakinsins...
Wait, I know this word, but I...
Uh...
How do I say it?
Like telekinesis, parakinesis, like telekinesis,
parakinesiology.
Also, I was right.
Has always been the stronger department.
More breakthroughs, more tangible data, more usable
research.
Parakinesiology.
I'm sure a man of your esteem can plainly see which
department is more deserving of the budget increase.
Just think of those additional resources, what those
additional resources could do for an already formidable
research team.
Anyway, I know you're a fan of a single malt, so I left a
bottle of well-aged brown on your desk.
Yours in admiration, Dr. Abraham Lewis.
This guy is a brown-nosing, bribing...
Everything that starts with a B to this guy.
Astral Plane.
The Bureau has spent years studying why objects of power
transport users into the astral plane when touched.
Our predecessor, Dr. Ash, theorized that a potential
receptacle determined by Jun-Gian archetypes and the
collective subconscious would be inhabited by paranatural
energies when an AWE occurred in its vicinity, creating an
altered item.
theology hey when you need more funding I guess I guess
creating an altered item over time a link was created by the
redacted and the astral plane to that item making it an
object of power so many additional theories have been raised
since dr. Ash's time objects of power were placed on earth
as tests by some astral entity our dimension was once part
of the astral plane and the objects were left behind as its
borders receded the astral plane was an early threshold into
the oldest house but the connection was severed and now the
two are linked solely through the objects of power i will
attempt to disprove some of these in order to thin the herd
hopefully the truth will be will emerge
interesting very very interesting this is classified you
guys This is classified.
Nice.
This game owns.
Ah, yes, yes, yes.
No, no, no.
Yes, yes, yes!
Birth, birth, birth!
I'll never understand why science majors love that thing.
I think it's because it's like such a...
Like a science like it is it is a creation that just shows
science so easily.
You know what I mean?
Dr. Darling is insistent that certain objects of power share
a direct connection to the Redacted and yeah, and it is fun
An entity group or group of entities that we have little
information on or little that I'm allowed to access And as
written reports he states that there is a clear link between
these objects of power and The redacted, the astral plane,
and the oldest house itself.
His work supposes these links are innate.
A fact ingrained into the very redacted of objects, such as
the hotline or the service weapon.
But what if these particular objects were never linked to
the redacted, but have that connection forced upon them?
Isn't it strange that no objects of power require such
direct contact with the redacted?
Isn't it strange that using the service weapon or the
hotline, will result in grievous harm or even death if the
user is not the director or at least worthy of the role why
do we assume this involvement by the redacted is a natural
fact and not something more
redacted interesting oh this game has so much going on my
brain how are you
okay i'm trying to find a uh control point
Oh, okay.
Maybe we're fine.
Dimensional research.
I'm scared.
Wait, it's one of these.
Possibly changing labyrinth.
You can never pass through.
Dimensional research.
Every measure of security.
Should I be going in here?
Tab toggle maze.
Oh, I thought I said toggle maze.
I was like, no way.
Wow.
Am I gonna die?
I see smiley faces.
I'm worried.
Oh, yeah.
I'm so old.
with.
Ashtray maze.
Wait, am I...
Oh, shoot.
Wait.
Am I screwed?
What are these?
Ashtray maze, my beloved?
Hey!
It just spat me back out!
It said, you are not worthy.
Okay, we'll actually come back to this then.
we'll come back to this like i said i'm trying to find a a
control point because i want to uh i do wanna i just wanted
to start the research area i didn't want to quite oh my gosh
that spooked me i knew it i knew it i knew it i knew it
that's right okay Maybe we're alright?
I think we're okay for now.
What does that sound?
We're not fine.
Oh my god.
Where did you come from?
You are such a weenie.
All you do is run away from me!
Yeah.
Quit running, you ween!
Quit running, you weenie!
Ah.
I knew I'd have to fight these guys again.
Going back and forth.
You know?
Maybe it's okay.
Let's go downstairs.
Maybe.
Parapsychology.
That's the thing we opened, but we can't...
Can we?
Oh, we can go through.
We are level three.
There's another guy, so...
I don't know where though.
Oh!
Oh, he's back!
He's back!
You can technically just run past him.
Yeah, that's true, but there's a huge pain in my behind.
Wait.
Is that what I think it is?
No.
It's not.
Oh, it's mold!
It's even better!
Oh, yeah!
Mold, mold, mold.
I feel like I could get through there.
Can you shoot the floating bodies?
You know, I haven't tried yet.
I think you can.
I think they just disappear Ignore the music nothing's
happening
Nothing nothing is wrong ignore the music Am I gonna have to
check every gosh darn stall Wait, what's that nothing
someone might left.
Someone left candy bars in the toilet.
Mm-hmm.
Nothing.
You cheapos.
Wow, I like this room.
Why is it so bright in here?
What's going on in here?
The toilets of the heavens.
My goodness.
It'd take only the holiest of poops in here or something.
Oh, that's not what I meant to do.
That's not my bad.
Oh.
Nothing else?
Okay, let's go.
Bathrooms made you feel as uncomfortable as possible.
Oh, but look!
There's a...
Oh, radio.
And some documents for lunch.
Black...
analysis.
Hi, Carla.
Does it strike you as odd that darling insists on having us
appear in those bizarre videos of his?
I mean, we just stand there.
He doesn't even let us have lines or anything.
Don't get me wrong.
Beats in the, beats a day in the lab.
Plus, it's great to work with you.
Boom.
Oh, yeah.
I've The comparative analysis of the two black rock samples
You sent the prism or whatever you call it I filed them in a
usual place under C for Carla A handy mnemonic device,
right?
Ha ha, anyway, let me know if there's anything you want To
discuss about the data I'll gladly explain Maybe we could
chat about it over some drinks or dinner even I can't
remember the last time I had a good steak Maybe we could go
together After work sometime I'm free to borrow all the best
Hubert.
Oh no, wait.
No, Hubert, don't ask Carla out.
I filed them under C for Carla.
He flirted with her and left it in the middle of the
cafeteria.
This is so awkward.
If I were Hubert, I would want to become one of the...
hiss to just hiss me now please whoa who are you put him out
of his misery oh shelter couple thank you and for anybody
who didn't know that oh major targets Wait, what is this?
Uh, not major.
Uh, that song is Black Rock Shooter.
Very famous.
So, wait, hold on.
What's this for?
Oh, no.
Go to pneumonics.
Numerics.
I don't even know what that is.
Another optional.
I have to pee.
But I'm trying to find.
Oh, my gosh.
This place is ginormous.
Uh-oh.
Lab 2 and 3.
are compromised we don't worry about them that's
where you fight tamasi oh i see okay let's try going in here
beep no don't beep beep mean oh geez okay i i you know what
i think it's fine i wanted to save at like a thing but there
just doesn't seem to be one around and that guy is still up
there in the window he's just dancing all around like a
freaking hippie oh seven to our father fallen brother hubert
uh surely the control room is there i don't know he was
listening to your song i haven't tried i know i think if you
shoot these guys they just turn into dust but i haven't
tried because i feel kind of bad doing it elevator will go
to executive yeah but then i have to here you know what i
mean and do everything all over again i don't really want to
dodge efficiency go check lab one okay
maybe one in lab one i'm trusting i'm trusting don't let me
down please
whoa Whoa.
Cool.
Don't trust.
I trusted.
I trusted you.
Betrayed but neat.
Yeah, but we could have gone here next time.
Hearing protection required.
I trusted you.
No, I'm not listening to you guys right now.
I'm trying to figure out...
I want to find a save point so I can stop.
I need to go party.
His sniper!
She's in trouble.
I need to reach her.
His sniper research.
This feels like one of the...
Plains, like...
...
things do this one fight and you'll find a save okay once
again trusting
this could have sworn I heard a splat sometimes
they get these guys low and I don't kill them
oh shoot oh my god one HP and a dream please don't kill me
Give me your health Give me your dots I just pick up
everything I don't check if it's a Flam if it's an explosive
Or not It's fine we're HP again We're full HP Let's go Whoa
You okay in there
Oh my god Everybody died and just left this guy to torture
Whoa Whoa uh oh
emergency call supplement transcript of a call to a
california state emergency services dispatcher 911 what's
wrong with you voice hello hello i'm here can you hear me i
can hear you ma'am where are you i'm uh inside the wires i'm
lost ma'am have you been drinking tonight voice i feel like
i'm stretching through the wire towards you don't hang up i
might go if you hang up go where ma'am go gone away okay Can
you describe your surroundings?
The wires!
Ma'am?
Hello, ma'am?
Dispatcher attempted to call the number back, but it was no
longer in service.
My eyes.
This is...
When you hear girls talking about red light therapy, if
you've ever heard that before, it's literally that.
Yeah.
Oh!
Wait, did more just...
Okay, I thought I heard some more baddies.
What is going on in these rooms?
There's a lot of sounds.
There's so many sounds.
The lights up the whole street.
Therapy for what?
Please explain.
Okay, so there's a thing called red light therapy.
It's quite...
It's almost a fad right now, but...
I guess it does have like, I don't know, I've not done
enough research.
I've only heard about it, but it says that it's supposed to
like help with, you know, like the LED, the red light LEDs
are on some, if they have like some sort of enough of a
frequency, it's supposed to help with like joint pain, but
then also they say that it can help with like skincare.
So that's why it's a fad.
I've seen someone with a mask for it.
Yeah, it's very like, it's a very common like, a red light
therapy mask yeah it helps with hair loss like again i don't
know any science behind it or anything like that um but i've
just that's just what i've seen so it's funny because the
girlies are like going insane about it they're like oh my
god did you run light therapy and there is some scientific
basis to it but all the products are entirely that's the
thing yes They're very unregulated.
So they'll be like, here, get your red light therapy mask
for $500.
Like quite literally, like quite literally $500.
But then it's not even like the, like strength of the, of
the LED that is like done in this research that says, that
suggests that like, you know, it's, it's worth it or like
working or whatever.
so yeah
so that's what's going on in there not me having to explain
my joke oh my god we found it
similar to an iceberg what you see is not what you always
get regardless this place is vitally important to the bureau
most information on the astral plane is classified but we
can talk in broad strokes keeping in mind these are
staggeringly complex systems and simplification does them no
justice now the white non-space the ever-present inverted
black pyramid yeah yeah the board the board linked
intrinsically tied there was a that room in the yeah the
room that we used choosing a director tied to all objects of
power in terms of who controls them.
Me?
Would you guys feel safe if I were in power?
That's nice, Adam.
Glad I helped your dad.
Like I said, I heard some things about it helping.
Who knows?
I mean, it could, but do your research.
That's all I'll always say about these kinds of things.
Do your research.
Yeah.
Can you hear me?
I'm in the wires.
I'm Stretching towards you.
Don't hang up, Minto.
Oh, actually, that's all the time we have for today's
stream.
Oh, well, I gotta hang up now, guys.
But don't touch that dial.
I'll be back.
Same Minto time.
Same Minto place.
Next time.
In the same place.
But a different time.
And also, yeah.
Uncapable.
Oh, incapable.
impeccable show of show of control director of the town in
the story may be called ordinary but you are extraordinary
I've never heard of comparative analysis in a song ever such
an epic love balance thank you for the pink door I go take
incapable I am incapable of anything who knows thank you
Vito I trust a minke Ki-moe leadership.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Make me thank you!
Yeah, I saw you guys saying yes.
You guys would feel safe and protected, and everything would
be moe and awesome, and there would be real cat girls!
Anime girls would be real!
A non-scam skincare tip.
Paraphen hot wax works and makes your skin look great.
My aunt uses it on her hands for other reasons, but her skin
looks peak.
Paraphen hot wax I'm gonna look that up that sounds fun and
I don't know should you use that on your face not sure but
okay what about vampire girls I will make all awesome girls
real I wish girls were real I wish girls were real and if
you elect me for director they will be real cat girls okay
i'm in me too me too put her in charge girls real you could
you probably can't imagine a reality where girls are real
but it could it could happen there's a parallel universe
right now or something I'll bring that universe over here
sadly the service weapons decide who's director I just gotta
appeal to them like L Woods in her video to Harvard I'm
gonna slap on a little bikini and be like look at my body
Ariari don't you want me to be director I'll direct you to
the nearest girl i'm john ibu and i approve this message
oh yeah i'll direct you to the maid cafe and i'll direct you
to the subscribe button don't forget to like the stream
subscribe to the channel and i will see you ibu next time I
love you, LWoods, or Stubb.
Whoa, Eastern Telecom.
Thank you so much for the five gifted.
What about Ghost Made VTubers?
Can they be real?
That's going to require extra research, but there's nothing
that's impossible.
Occurs to me, Harry Potter would be way different with a
service weapon instead of the sword again.
The boy who lived is the boy who becomes the director.
I'll hit that subscribe button bucket I gotta get out of
here thank you so much we'll continue control next week next
week next week um yeah
thank you so much for the five good to thank you bye bye bye
thank you guys thank you so much thank you thank you thank
you bye bye bye bye bye bye Bye.